I It's like actually just mind-blowing. This is mind-blowing.
It's He's never in a forum where somebody Thank you. That Now
that is the response. Let it out. Like just Let it out, you know?
Yeah, he lied about that, for sure. >> lied. For sure,
he lied. Okay, but then WHAT THEN MAYBE OUR GUY should lie about
some things that are popular, too.
You did good, Hutch. Can we get claps? Claps in the chat for
Hutch. I just I love to see somebody who will actually go back
and admit they were wrong.
Man, do we just hop right into Hasan at Pod Save Con? I might
just hop right in
Like maybe this is just what we do today. Hasan at Crooked Con.
Pod Save America guy co- hosting it.
Tina Fey apparently on the stage. Some sassy black lady. I think
this is Symone Sanders, right? Then Hasan and Tim Not Tim Burton,
not Tim Dillon. It's Tim Tim Tim Tim I can't remember his name.
The Bulwark guy. Who's the Bulwark guy? What's his name? I actually
I literally don't remember. Miller. Tim Miller. Thank you. Tim
Miller. How do you know she's sassy? Cuz she did some sassy stuff
in the in the coverage I saw this in like the one clip I saw
of this. She like stands up
stands up and like snaps her fingers in Hasan's face. Okay?
Straight up. Straight up. Not even joking. She does that. That's
real. That's true. That's accurate. Is that Jessica Tarlov? I
have got no idea. I'm guessing they'll introduce themselves.
Let's get into it. Hi everybody.
I'm Jon Lovett. We're live AT CROOKED
ALL RIGHT, HE'S GOT PEOPLE. EVERYBODY HERE HAS GOT PEOPLE EVERYWHERE,
you We're in the Reagan building, baby. I've co-opted your app.
Can't lose control just yet. In his 1992 convention speech, Bill
Clinton >> Oh, I also just noticed
It says all of the names. I I literally just had to look at the
title and it says all of the names, so >> who is perfect.
Set of Republicans who were at the time angry about Murphy Brown
being a single mom on television.
If other politicians make you feel like you're not part of their
family, come on and be part of our >> Yes, this is Jon
Lovett. >> Republicans were the hall monitors, we were
welcoming.
Three decades later, Trump found an audience among pretty apolitical
comedians and media personalities and their fans who see Democrats
as pious and scolding. The Democratic Party is widely reviled.
A broad survey of working-class voters described Democrats as
quote woke weak and out of touch. Coming out of Tuesday, which
was awesome, Semafor's Dave Woke Sharia. What? Yeah. >> woke
Sharia, baby.
We're all living in Mom Dana stan now.
Semafor's Dave Weigel put it best in summarizing the exit polls.
What do you think of the Democrats? They stink. Who did you vote
for? As many Democrats as
So where do we go from here? Uh joining me are street >> Oh,
the the title or the topic of this is why don't people like Democrats?
Why don't people like Democrats? And honestly, I feel like some
of the people on this panel really drive it home for me. Like
directly with some of their answers. I haven't watched even close
to I've watched like one answer on any of this. So I haven't
watched a lot, but I I just know, okay? Spiritually, I can see
exactly what's going to happen. >> Dreamer and political
commentator Hasan
MSNBC Symone Sanders
The Bulwark's Tim Miller and the co-host of The Five
Fox News' Jessica Tarlov. Tim, I want to start with you and I
want to just concede that this is like a big topic and it can
be hard to sing to tease out style from substance,
uh strategy, ideology, but I want to start with the back 2024
dynamic. You have Trump and his allies on Rogan and a whole bunch
of apolitical uh shows and media uh In hindsight, Democrats say,
"Oh, we need Democrats that can go everywhere. They have to go
everywhere just like Trump did." But then we look around and
we say, "Well, who are the Democrats that can do that?" And as
a former Republican, as a pilgrim in an So if you guys are following,
this is going to be the Ezra Klein, okay? Abundocrats versus
I guess anybody who's presenting like a socialist vision, a a
more social democrat vision. Right? Which direction do you go
in? How do you message? How do you start to get people to like
Democrats again? To like you know, aspects of the Democratic
Party again. Some people will say just winning, right? As long
as you win, you you'll get you'll win people over. So that's
where the abundocrats, the the people who say, "Oh, we need the
pro-life Dems and stuff like that." That's where those people
will be coming from, right? unholy land who's gone from viewing
Democrats being annoying as an
to a liability. Like what where is your head at? Um well, I was
happy about the woke Sharia in New York, but you do have to remember
that the CIA has taken over in Virginia across the river. So
the deep state establishment is also on the rise. Um Big tent.
Big tent.
Um I You know what, Lovett? You guys are kind of annoying. Um
and it is it is something that we're dealing with. And I just
I think that it's important to just accept it and think about
it. And um that that what you the fundamental question you got
to, which was um okay, well, we need a Rogan of our own or we
got to be able to go hang out with these uh you know, folks.
We got to be appealing more to the comedian set. And then it's
like, "Well, who would go on the podcast?" And then it's like,
"Well,
are you available?
Are you? Um I like the list is kind of short, right? And so um
you know, we can't create people from scratch, but I think that
it's important, you know, when I look back at the mistakes the
Democrats made that got us to this place, it's like and like
Bi- Biden wins in '20 when you're everybody's inside, right?
So you didn't The diversion. Every time Why are you talking about
[__] that happened? Are you good? >> out there.
And then in '22, it's like we didn't have a red wave. So it's
like things are going pretty well, right? No spoilers. I just
think that there was a lot of um just inertia and status quo
happening. And a lot of the problems that were under that were
undergirding that, a lot of things people were frustrated with
about COVID or about uh you know, um the the the not as fun parts
of woke Sharia, right? Like um uh there wasn't a lot of reflection
on that and I think that it's good to reflect on it now and I
think that Tuesday was awesome, but just because we did really
well on Tuesday because Trump has everything up does not mean
that we shouldn't also like think about how we can continue to
kind of expand out uh and appeal to more people. Symone
Uh it seems like Democrats are often in a trap, which is Trump
or one of his acolytes does something Man, I just to go through
a little bit of what Tim Miller said there.
I don't know I don't know what the better path is. It sucks that
Republicans will just get people who do podcasts and like make
them make them their candidates and then those people have no
idea how to govern. They have no idea what politics is at all.
It's very sad. It's very gross, right?
I don't know what what way to go is if that's like the only way
to win elections. Do you even want to win election? Like
What do you I don't know what you're doing then.
So it's it's kind of funny when he talks about, "Oh, we need
more people. It's People say you should do that." And he's like,
"Oh yeah, we have a short list." It's like, "Well, you could
you start Do you start making the politicians the people who
can do that? Cuz I think there is a disconnect when it's just
people who are personalities and have no connection to politics.
When they're the ones who are going on the podcast talking about
policies and stuff, people feel like there's no investment. There's
no skin in the game. So I don't know if they take it as seriously.
It's like a big deal when the actual politician can go on and
be compelling. That's like a way different animal. something
genuinely offensive, whether it's attacking or undermining a
democratic institution or going after a vulnerable group of people.
And Democrats want to defend those people, right? But then at
times sometimes they seem like they're writing their own version
of the Federalist
or they are doing what is then described as identity politics.
Trans How do you Trans people. What What do you support? Trans
people. back against Trump when he's attacking people, when he's
making an issue of marginalized groups without then being seen
by a broader group of being focused less on say the economy.
Like how do you square that circle? So how do you help trans
people? How do you lean into that identity without losing track
of the everyday American? How can you take a marginalized group,
which by definition is probably a small portion of the of the
overall population? How can you make their issues matter, make
them things that you can run on, but also not forget about the
small voter. I think the sorry, the average voter. I think the
answer to that is when things are going really well, you can
focus on stuff like that. When things are not going really well,
that messaging needs to fall by the wayside. And you got to hope
that people aren't going to argue I guess what happened here
is stuff went off the rails and Trump went, "You guys care You
guys care so much about all these marginalized group. What about
the average American?"
I think at some point you need to go, "Well, no, we care most
about the average American, most about everyday working issues
that that affects
Right? And I think that's the issue with Democrats they didn't
step back from their their like marginalized groups messaging.
They didn't step back from it and go, "No, no, no, that's like
That is important, but it's nowhere near as important as as the
economy and stuff like that." I think they had a hard time distancing
from the past messaging.
What was Kamala going to do for trans people other than playing
sports? Uh Dude, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The the issue is Democrats got stuck with a label they previously
embraced even though they didn't run on it. But they didn't do
a good job of distancing themselves. They needed to somehow distance
from that label and they didn't want to do that. They felt like
that was a betrayal of their principles and Republicans hammered
them on that to the point they won an election. Like a presidential
election. Right? R- Democrats did not want to distance from like
this this identity of protecting trans people, protecting trans
like fighting for trans issues or or positively in favor of trans
people on certain issues, right? And they did they didn't want
to go, "No, no, no, we don't want to do that anymore." They wanted
to go, "Well, we're not running on that now." It's like, "Okay,
but what if you get in power? And so they Republicans just kept
hammering on them and and Dems didn't want to distance and it
I think it it hurt in a lot of key places. You think it was trans
people that did it? I'm just talking about the poll even less
in Pennsylvania that showed that that was the most effective
ad. It's basically like that talking point,
I don't think trans people or trans issues by themselves won
or lost the election, obviously. I'm talking about something
that's basically like a narrative that people have come away
from the election with, right? That Dems didn't feel like I mean,
you just look at how certain places shifted. It seems like a
lot of core demographics fractured for Democrats in a way that
wasn't expected.
Like a lot of minority groups especially along, you know, gender
lines, males broke towards Republicans in a way that wasn't expected.
Anyway.
We keep going. >> Well, you know, I'm from um North Omaha,
Nebraska. Shout out to the Midwest people in the room. Yes, there
are black people There are black people in Nebraska all over
this country. Maybe not North Dakota.
And so I say that because The [__] cuz earlier this
summer a black man who is a Democrat
unseated a three-term Republican mayor in Omaha, Nebraska. And
we can clap for that. His name is John Ewing.
Um and John Ewing I I grew up knowing John Ewing. I know him
very well. But in that race, like in many other races across
this country that have happened since 2024,
one of the issues that the Republican candidate tried to, you
know, pull to the forefront were a bathrooms and trans issues.
And you know what John Ewing's answer was? Well, first of all,
he had an answer. He put up an ad to answer the attacks, which
I think is really important. You cannot let attacks go. You cannot
allow your your opponent as a former strategist, you cannot have
the your opponent defining you and you not answering. So that's
part of it. I
That That would be like a very key way of describing it. You
can't let your opponent describe you or define you and you not
have an answer for it. You don't have to like constantly answer
it, right? But you should have some answer so that if you're
if you're asked in a key place where you where you're more You're
asked in a key place where you have to answer and you are expected
to answer. You should have that answer like memorized, locked
down, so you don't look like a
Right? You could You could say oh, I don't want to talk about
this. You could filter it out of your appearances, but if you
never talk about it, that's bad. If you dodge it when it comes
up, when you're forced to answer it, it's also bad. Give me a
second. Ribbin' and ribbin' with three.
Specifically coming out of 2024, a lot of candidates did not
answer the attacks. And some people were just like, oh no, no,
that's not me. And it's like, well, who are you? But John Ewing
put up ads and went out there and did speeches and was on the
streets talking to folks, doing the doing interviews and whatnot
and and campaigning and saying, she's doing this cuz she don't
want to talk about the potholes.
She doesn't want So I think the big thing with Harris substance
wasn't that she couldn't answer those questions or that she didn't
have answers.
It was that
broadly her answers just factually, even if she had them, were
going to be hypocrisy, right? Because she constantly moralized
all of these issues and she has no way to explain the switch.
So she could have answers on like why she's not focusing on it
now, but she kind of hemmed herself into being a hypocrite, right?
With how she constantly moralized the issues like these people
are terrible for not supporting this. So like it she could answer,
she could even have the answers memorized, but the answers wouldn't
actually make people
have more faith in her. I think they would have just hurt. So
like she was she was caught between a rock and a hard place on
the trans issue specifically. I think on like some race issues
as well, like some DEI stuff, they they continued to like lean
into weird race stuff during the campaign. I remember the Tim
Walls Kamala Harris sit-down where Tim Walls was talking about
they they like talked about how white people ain't got no seasoning,
white people like like mayonnaise and tuna and it was like the
weirdest condescending race thing where it's like aren't you
trying to get like white guys to be psyched about voting Dem?
Like why Where did that go? Where did that go?
I don't know. I think For me Kamala Harris just had issues of
like she factually
kind of either believed or she she bit way too hard into some
of the identity politics stuff and I don't think she had an effective
way to distance without looking like a total hypocrite. want
to talk about the issues that are affecting you. She's going
to make up this issue that have you I'm not talking about. She
doesn't want to talk about the potholes. And so I think the answer
is not to run away from the confrontation.
Like you're not about to make me as I used to always tell candidates,
don't allow these folks, anybody, any of your opponents to to
make you believe believe that you're for an issue that you've
you've never taken up. Like I don't know what the hesitancy is
from some of the campaigns and the strategists over the last,
you know, couple of cycles to just not be clear about what folks
are for and what they're not for. Because in 2024 that they/them
ad was seen everywhere. And black people in Philadelphia told
me the organizers in Philadelphia said that everybody had talked
Come on. When did she dodge interviews? Joe Rogan and that's
it? Uh I thought she was asked to be on like a lot of different
things and didn't end up going on. I thought she also didn't
even go on like lefty stuff. Like she was supposed to go on lefty
stuff and she basically dodged a lot of lefty stuff, too. Like
they they just weren't doing They were doing like local radio
ads, like those those interviews, right? What else did she not
do? She didn't do Joe Rogan. I think Theo Von was the other one.
But I can't think of any others off the top of my head except
Was it Pacman or was
Was it BTC who couldn't talk to her? Somebody like wanted to
talk to her and couldn't. saw that ad and there was no counter
and they believed it. So I I do think that I don't think Democrats
need to do a wholesale like
you need a full brand rebrand because I think frankly the Democratic
Party brand, it might never be popular. But what may be And that's
okay because what what you need are candidates who people like
and they want to vote for and who they believe in. And whether
brand is popular or not, I'm not I I think the Democrats need
to be less concerned about rehabilitating the brand of the Democratic
Party apparatus and more Um what was it? Uh that was part of
the Republican propaganda, wasn't it, that she would say they
would just say she refuses interviews. I think they said she'd
only use softball interviews.
Right? That you'd only do softball interviews and then the support
for that was or that she couldn't do harder interviews and she
did the interview with Bret Baier and Bret Baier was straight
up like trying to tank her campaign and she handled it just fine.
So yeah, there was some amount of
Republican propaganda going on there. I don't think I don't remember
if it was like dodging interviews. She definitely didn't go on
Rogan, which was something that was used against her.
Yeah. more concerned about running candidates that are close
to the issues in the districts and places that they're trying
to win.
Ho- Hold on. Was that Symone Sanders for abundance Democrats?
>> rehabilitating the brand of the Democratic Party apparatus
and more concerned about running candidates that are close to
the issues in the districts and places that they're trying to
win.
Justin Seems that way, yeah. Tim Tim don't agree. I I know. I
mean, the brand is The brand is it's bad, but the brand was poopoo.
Is the Is the Tim guy Was the Tim guy like giving her sass or
what? Oh, he was Was he giving a little sass
What's the face? What's this What's this face he's doing? She
didn't like the face that he did after she answered. Tim don't
agree.
She couldn't She couldn't let the face go. He's just like, dude,
this is just my face. It's just my face. Don't go after me for
my face.
Tim Tim don't agree. I I know. I mean, the brand is The brand
is it's bad, but the brand was poopoo and people voted
anyway. So to me that says people are willing to support candidates
even if they think your brand is [__] Well, I think
I think that I don't know. I think it's an important part of
what I think the dynamic we see, right? Which is a you know,
there's there was just a uh uh
report that came out that said, "Oh, here is here's a set of
policies that are broadly popular that Democrats should embrace
going into the midterms and they're pretty moderate and and and
sort of Oh, a bunch of these people that lost some races and
hadn't won recently put this report out? Yeah, it was shocking.
I I was I for one was shocked when I saw that report. I was like,
"Wow, so do the exact same thing that the Democrats have been
doing that caused them a sequence of failures?
That's That's good. I like that." I I knew there was no way moderate
enough. That was what Her some reactions there. Hold on. We got
to back it up. We got to do We got to do some actual reactions
from This person does not like Hasan. Did you just see that?
for one was shocked when I saw that report. I was like, "Wow,
so do the exact same thing that the Democrats have been doing
that caused them a sequence of failures?
That's good. I like that." I there was I knew there was no way
moderate enough. That was what the issue was. I was There was
no way I was going to get to the end of that sentence. I don't
even know why I considered starting it, but I taken, but uh what
I what I when I hear what you're saying there, when I see a report
like that, I see a group of people struggling against a brand
that is in the toilet and a bunch of people trying to win despite
that, which is another way of saying we're in a ravine, let's
find the highest spot we can here in this trench that we're stuck
in. But there's the the reason I think this question's important,
even if you're right, like people win despite disliking the Democratic
Party, people hate Congress, like their Congressperson. Uh I
do think it's worth asking to what it is like to imagine a world
in which Democrats are broadly popular.
That is a world where quality of life isn't going to continue
going down in the US because low-skill labor is going to continue
to be devalued. Even sorry, all labor is going to continue to
be devalued. Labor is just being devalued in general. For as
long as Oh, what's up, Hidalgos13?
Welcome to the channel. Dude, it first like For as long as labor
continues to be devalued and the average person can't get a job,
can't get like an a level of income that's going to allow them
to prosper in America, yeah, of course people are going to be
What's confusing? It's so It's so not confusing at all. How many
gummies you take before coming out here?
So, which brings me to Jessica. Uh
sorry, that actually wasn't a complete answer. You've got two
options. Either you make America better for people, you make
America better, which is super easy to understand and also almost
impossible to do right now in the current economic conditions.
I don't know how you make America better without major paradigm
shifts in some Right? Like massively increasing taxes somehow
and not having wealth leave the country or I don't even know.
I actually don't know. It's like an It's an almost unsolvable
problem right now.
Or you start you start doing like populist lies. You start doing
populist lies, you start lying to people saying you can't make
it better. You try to win and then you go for some sort of some
sort of like autocracy of your own. Like That seems Those are
the two playbooks. You find a way to make things
in in some genius fashion that nobody else can think of or
you try to win elections through populism, form your own autocracy.
I don't know. Those Those are the two playbooks I see
And currently the Democrats aren't even in one of those playbooks.
They're like They don't really have a plan to make things better.
They're just like, "Oh, maybe things be like will be like marginally
less bad." That's That's basically the brand of Democrats and
liberals in general. We're going to make things marginally less
bad, maybe. It's I Kind of a losing strategy right now. I'll
be real.
So, I I will reveal something to all of you,
which is John, Tommy, and I share an
And we often, if not more often than not now, switch over to
Fox News during the day. And we do because we we want to see
what's happening over there. But also, it's entertaining. It
is. They're having fun over there. >> True story. And
uh Jessica, I want you to talk about like what it is like to
be in that environment because part of what is so fun is their
just collective appreciation
and shared view of Democrats, which is that they're kind of feckless
and funny and ridiculous.
They definitely enjoy that part of it. And I'm so glad that this
conference is this week and not last week cuz we'd all just be
sitting around crying and looking at that memo and saying, "Well,
you know, this is 57% popular, so I think we should go with that."
But now we have some wins and we have this diverse set of wins.
So, I have had a way better couple of days. Um They've been almost
circumspect. >> Oh, yeah. I mean, sometimes they got a
little rowdy. Oh, this is just to be I think this is right after
Mondaire won.
Like when this took place. So, I think it's about a week old,
this this panel, but they just put it up yesterday or the day
before. >> Who, but I you know, you can't
dispute results like that. You can't dispute a Mondaire win and
a Spanberger win and whatever happened in the Mississippi State
House. And I'm obsessed with whatever a public commissioner is
in Georgia. Like you Um I still don't know what that >> shows
up to vote, we win. Yeah.
It's important
to remember. But the
the joy is important.
Uh Substance, we don't ask that question, but okay. All right,
it seems like that's the way it is. I'll leave the chat there
for for today.
Yeah, we'll see.
it's always on our side, I think, since the 2016 election. It
feels like it's forced upon us versus it's coming from within.
There may be individual candidates that we're into. I've gotten
super excited about people, you know, down ballot all over the
place or, you know, I I love Ruben Gallego. Like that's always
fun for me to talk about. But the because we have this
kind of uniform policy of stay in line, it's joyless because
you can't feel free to criticize somebody that you disagree with
or, you know, you're going to get scolded by this person and
that person. And the Republicans, generally speaking,
live free of that amongst themselves. I mean, criticizing Trump
is a whole other thing. But they go about their business in a
way that we don't. And that I think that we're adapting to in
at least based on these election results. And Fox captures that
that there are people who have kind of like a shared core set
of values, maybe, but they're not taking themselves that seriously.
They're not scolding each other. Like it also matters in the
quality of the programming. It looks great. Our graphics are
beautiful.
I think this is just cope. I It's This is just total cope. It
Your graphics don't matter, dude. What are you talking about?
>> Our lighting is fantastic. Are you making a face?
Did you NONE OF THAT [__] MATTERS. YES, OH [__]
LISTEN, I WANTED TO SUCK ON HASAN, but that's just a king move
to just laugh at this woman who's talking about totally irrelevant
[__] Nobody gives a [__] about what the
graphics are. They care about how funny it is, how good the programming
is, how entertaining it is. Nobody gives a [__]
Look, I'm your I'm your fedayeen. I'm your biggest Hasan fan,
okay? But no, I don't think the Fox News graphics are are beautiful.
Like I I respect what you do, especially cuz like if I had to
sit next to Jesse Waters and Greg Buttfeld the entire time, I
would kill myself.
And the fact that you have been able to successfully
sit in that room every day and just white-knuckle through Jesse
Waters' snide ass remarks
is impressive.
It is.
When suddenly you Thank you. And it is nice to be amongst my
people, which I'm usually not.
Like cautiously weaving through here. But my point in bringing
it up, and you don't have to love our graphics, even though they're
copied in every movie and things like that. It's like the official
look of it. But But even when >> people love Jessica.
She is a favorite of the Fox PR folks.
nothing is taken that seriously.
What's up, Saagar Enjeti? What's going on? >> the case
in liberal media. And that doesn't mean you're not talking about
serious things, but there's this feeling like it is not the end
of the world in every topic that you're discussing.
And
this idea
that we can just go and show up in conservative spaces or, you
know, come for an hour and you have to be open to those kinds
of things. Like doesn't capture
how hard it is for people who vote like me and some of the I
mean, is this This is literally just subjective, Krystal Ball
Enjeti.
I'd say saying they just don't matter is is more accurate, but
I I'd say the he disagreed with the idea that they matter, too,
did he not? Felt like he It's just not a big deal in any case.
>> that I think to Nobody Nobody cares about what the ticker
looks like, okay? genuinely
form bonds and interact on a ongoing basis with people who you
disagree with. An hour, two hours, three hours is not getting
to know the other side.
Living amongst them and spending time with them is. And I think
that's why I'm able to do my job and have a reasonable therapy
bill. Like not insane, but you know, we know each other like
the family that it looks like, which is dysfunctional, but it's
still a family. And people who watch the show, and you know,
we have 20% Democratic viewership, like still get that.
I'm sorry. I I know it's not maybe not the answer you guys wanted,
but You're not getting a lot of class cuz you're defending Fox
News in this room. Well, I think Let me Let me speak. I I want
to talk to Hasan about about what you just said. But before I
I I heard something from the crowd and I think it just reflects
what they're feeling, which is, well, they're not taking it seriously
because
because these are people that are not appreciating the consequences
or or are playing or telling themselves a story about the consequences.
And I know you know that.
But that's a challenge for the left. I think sometimes we are
seen as uh upset or uh uh uh scolding because we're motivated
by like a deep set of values.
Lefties would call her a a shill, by the way.
Oh, I don't know if this is even lefty anymore, BB Poison. I
think I think even a lot of lefties have sort of abandoned
the identity It's like a different group of people who are still
on that that tiny little island of identity politics. Like honestly,
a lot of leftists, like I don't I don't know if Hasan's there.
Hasan's probably like about being nice to people, but most people
I I think Hasan already said he was like one of her biggest fans.
And most people who are like leftists in general aren't really
on the identity politics in the same way anymore. I think a lot
of people have moved past it. They've realized it's kind of silly.
news. And when you watch Fox, there's a frivolousness to it,
but maybe that's a kind of carelessness about what's happening
to the country. I I totally agree with you about certain issues.
Absolutely. And I make that very clear. And they can make fun
of me or whatever. But elections have consequences. And we saw
on Tuesday night that the American public sees through it. That's
the point. Like
people get all hot and bothered about how conservatives are reacting
to certain things and that they're being dismissive. But they're
the ones that think the American public is stupid. And we're
the ones who know that they can see what's going on. So, whether
you got 90 seconds of talk time Sorry, the American public is
What What are you talking about? The American public is [__]
stupid.
Probably every public is, but especially the American public,
okay? or you got talk for hours a day on your podcast or on your
live stream all the things for Hasan.
they're the ones that doubt are doubting people's capacity to
understand. And so I I get what you're saying and I feel it and
some I don't like being made fun of sometimes for being upset
about American citizens taken into ICE detention and not getting
to call their loved ones. But Tuesday night, people showed up
all over the country and said, "Fuck off. That is unacceptable."
This episode is brought to you by
The holidays come fast. You're decorate Stop. Hasan
I got to pause.
Hasan hasn't gone 17 minutes without talking since 2014.
This This stage is dying right now. This stage is vibrating
and I'm sorry it took this long to get to Sorry, I will say that
is like a big thing. I used to have people on all the time, right?
And I used to be very like okay with not talking. And then on
the occasion where I do actually have somebody in a conversation
who's like who's like talking back and forth with me, sometimes
if they like cut me off when I'm like trying to expand on a thought,
I get so [__] triggered like for a second in my brain.
I like have to train myself to not get upset about it,
I'm so used to being able to like construct my thoughts on the
fly with like not really not really worried about the other person
or anyone interrupting me and then having somebody interrupt
that process is very very It can be like very triggering.
It's kind of funny.
Uh I empathize. >> what we saw in New York on Tuesday in
many ways feels like an antidote to some of this problem. You
know, Zoran Mamdani is having fun out there. And he's also representing
a like incredibly enthusiastic base base of people who are finding
community in being part of politics. And that does seem like
something now that is more easily formed on the left. I can think
of all the candidates and campaigns that have been left driven
that have built that energy and enthusiasm and sense of fun.
Brett Somers wasn't exception. There was a moment where look,
we can all look back and be like, I knew we I was full I went
full Brett. >> I was there. >> We were yeah. And
that No, I I and as someone who was there at the DNC before I
got kicked out, but uh um on the last day, I actually found myself
uh feeling Um you DIDN'T GET KICKED OUT. YOU JUST GOT TOLD YOU
COULDN'T HAVE LIKE WORKING INTERNET. That's not the same AS GETTING
KICKED OUT. YOU'RE LYING.
SORRY, I just wanted to simulate what we're going to see from
most people who hear that clip. They're going to lose their minds
a little bit, okay? I just had to simulate that for you. >> feeling
a sense of anxiety
uh over the course of of every single day that passed where I
was like, "Why is everybody just like Hutch cele I think Hutch
did do this. I when I say I think, I mean that's the only version
I watched was like 30 sec I watched like Hutch's intro to this,
okay? Hold on. Hold on. Actually
He did it. I literally have to go find it right now. I just have
to Hold on. I have to go find it right now. Somers wasn't exception.
There was a moment where look, we can all look back and be like,
I knew we I was full I went full >> I was there. >> We
were yeah. And that No, I I and as someone who was there at the
DNC before I got kicked out, but uh
on the last day, I actually found myself
Just to be clear, he did not get kicked out of the DNC. He got
kicked out of like the VIP like sky tower. I don't know why he
got kicked out. They made room for I think some major publication.
I'll make it up and say New York Times. I think he I'm pretty
sure it was a politician explicitly.
Believe I believe I watched that I believe Sorry, I'm positive
what he was told was it was a big politician was coming in. I
don't know if that was determined. He got kicked out shortly
after he rolled his eyes and let out a uh when an Israeli citizen
who had a family member that was uh a hostage still in Gaza at
that point and they referenced I think well violence on October
7th and Hasan did a
did hold that thing. And I think he got kicked out of the skybox
shortly after that. Wait, was that the same day?
I don't think it had Yeah, no, I I don't think it had anything
to do with that.
Hutch is just correct. Wait, your hero you you understand this
is the same thing I just said, right? Hutch just said what I
said.
Um he didn't get kicked out. He just got kicked out of the area
with reliable internet that he said he needed to even stream
there in the first place. That's all he did and he wanted to
keep doing his stream, but that's not the same as kicking you
out. >> Like well, for the purpose of streaming it, that
was kicking him out. That is just true.
Uh at which, you know,
fair. Probably not great to have Well, the thing was, Sofia,
was that the
was not good in the rest of the area. We saw that when I believe
Not Sorry Nate was taking phone around trying to interview people
and the internet dropped like a thousand times. There were too
many people in there. You can't just use the Wi-Fi to stream.
You will constantly drop. You'll constantly have issues, right?
And Hasan knew that, so he said, "I'll I'll go, but I need somewhere
with like a hard line."
And then he got kicked out of the place with the hard line. He
said, "Well, I'm just going to go back to my hotel so I can actually
stream." That is getting kicked If you went there to do a job
and they take away your ability to do the
I feel like if you decide to go finish your job somewhere, that's
getting kicked out. That's equivalent to getting kicked out.
I don't think that's even weird to represent it that way. Someone
like that, you know, in your VIP Which by the way, Hasan was
straight up like talking [__] about me on his streams
at this exact time last year when I talked about it. And I had
the same opinion then. So that like he absolutely was getting
kicked out because he couldn't do his job without having the
hard line.
That was That was my opinion then. That's my opinion now.
skybox
at the DNC.
Um selves uh feeling a sense of anxiety
uh over the course of of every single day that Uh Hasan's mentioned
me on his stream before, yeah. Hasan knew who I was. passed where
I was like, "Why is everybody just like celebrating like we're
at the end zone here when it is not a guarantee that Kamala Harris
is going to win." And I kept warning over and over again that
there were a lot of unaddressed issues that the Democrats just
kind of never wanted to acknowledge at all. And Could we not
just be excited we had somebody who could talk though? Could
we just have had one week? We were excited for a week cuz she
could talk. >> I I but I think that was great. So I just
give us a break. No, but the ink the ex the excitement that came
into the DNC was actually because
Okay, hold on. I'm going to go back to this. I'm going to watch
>> celebrating like we're at the end zone here when it
is not a guarantee that Kamala Harris is going to win. And I
kept warning over and over again that there were a lot of unaddressed
issues that the Democrats just kind of never wanted to acknowledge
at all. And Could we not just be excited we had somebody who
could talk though? Could we just have had one week? We were excited
for a week cuz she My headphones
That's so annoying. Give me a second. Fixing them and then I'll
be right back.
They're going to reconnect.
It's They definitely just cut me off talking, but it's okay.
We're back. >> excited we had somebody who could talk.
We're not back. We're not
never wanted to acknowledge at all. And >> not just be
excited we had somebody who could talk though? Could we just
have had one week? We were excited for a week cuz she could talk.
So that was great. So I just give us a break. >> No, but
the ink the ex the excitement that came into the DNC was actually
because for for some reason, right? And the reason is because
people finally realized Joe Biden was, you know, his brain was
leaking out of his ear. I'm sorry. And And for that reason, I
know there's probably a lot of Democratic Party staffers in here
that are going to give me a really hard time for me saying this,
but um it almost felt like we had a competent party for once
and they were responsive to the people's needs. And that's the
reason why everyone was excited. I was excited. When I saw Kamala
Harris choose Tim Walz um when she could have just as easily
gone with Josh Shapiro, for example, I was like, "Oh my god,
is this like is this happening? Is there like an actual progressive
momentum backing this candidacy backing this campaign?"
And then they back pocketed him. And Kamala Harris went from
saying that she was going to do price controls and and she actually
very decently messaged around that by saying, "We're just going
to go after price gougers, right?" at the grocery store. Um which
was her most popular policy at the time and directly addressed
one of the Tim Miller, yeah, Dustin Sucks. I do
there's probably an argument for the political strategy around
ending the shutdown. Perhaps not exactly when they did. I've
heard that there's like a there's an argument for it. All right?
I don't necessarily agree, but I like I don't think it's totally
[__] insane.
And yeah, I've seen I think I've seen what Tim Miller's argument
would be. of the main economic anxiety that people people were
experiencing.
And then, lo and behold, her her brother-in-law who's, you know,
head of legal at at Uber came on and was like, "Cut this this
economic populism [__] out." And and then you had
$50,000
uh in in tax credits for small business owners. And that was
not addressing the problems that people were experiencing.
And I think that we have to we have to do the the the honest
autopsy of this campaign. And I've Let's be honest, okay? If
we're going to do an honest
he's talking about Kamala still, right? I don't think economic
populism was the way for Kamala to win. I think she had too many
things working against her there. I'm not sure if wins in any
case. I don't think it's like
Like I think the best the best economic populism Trump did was
no tax on tips and didn't Kamala just steal that? When she just
like yeah, that's mine. I got that. No tax on tips. We're going
to do that, too.
I think so. And realize that maybe people were excited for the
the progressive momentum that they perceived the campaign actually
was going to have and the responsiveness that the party finally
had to the people's desires of the to the base of voters desires,
but then they kind of just threw that into the wind and just
kept pumping Liz Cheney and and and refused to talk about Sorry
for lying to
Poor Liz Cheney. Liz Cheney Can I just do one thing on the honest
thought autopsy though cuz here I I I'm I actually we can find
some common ground on the economic populist stuff. I think that
Kamala should have probably in retrospect obviously been like
had a more tangible message on economic populism. My problem
with the Walls thing though is that that that relates to the
topic of this panel is that I I think if we're having an honest
autopsy and looking back at the campaign, there were a lot of
liberals that live on the on the coast that were like whoa, this
dude can change a carburetor
and I can put on a camo hat like Dude, there was like some thought
oh yeah, Tim Walls is so masculine and cool and like we're absolutely
Dude, this is going to solve our problem with men. I'm like what?
The most progressive governor in like the entire United States,
really? He's going to really that like that guy is really going
to connect with rural America cuz he seems like a guy that really
connects with rural America. Yes, they're talking about Walls.
They're talking about
I'm sorry. Walls was not the guy. I I understand people like
Walls. He was not the guy. I'm He was not the guy. Come on, man.
He wasn't the guy. He obviously wasn't the guy. And people who
like grew up in rural America who are who lived in red spaces
were like no, like that is the guy who is was the P flag teacher
at the rural high school. And by the way, being the P flag sponsor
at a rural high school is awesome. That's a great thing to be.
That everybody loves that. That's great. But like everybody who's
from that world did not look at him and say you code conservative
or like you have conservative values like me. They coded him
as like oh, you're the nice liberal at the school, right? And
so I think that if we're going to have an honest reflection on
the last campaign, the economic populism stuff was a miss, too.
Was a miss for sure, but the but being seen as being to the cultural
left and being out of step with the with the country culturally
on a wide variety of issues with
Ah, he's saying something perfectly correct here and I feel like
nobody will be able to see it, right? He's saying something that
is 100% correct that he was out of step culturally with most
of the country. Right? Yes, the left is culturally out of step
with a lot of the country. That is true. And and he's saying
he was perceived that way. He was perceived that way. Which is
100% true. You can't even argue with what he's saying cuz that
is just straight up that he is perceived that way. He's seen
that way. Okay? That's that's obvious.
I think
it might have been that he was that way,
But I think I think people are going to probably get mad at this
Tim Miller guy because he's saying the perception was not there.
It it definitely wasn't. There's just no way to argue it was
there. Whether it be social issues or COVID or free speech or
just being able to chill on comedians podcast, like that was
a miss and it was a and and people misunderstood what Tim Walls
was bringing to the table. I think cuz he was not able to do
any of >> Yeah, I think the cultural stuff is only relevant
if that is ostensibly the only thing that you're bringing to
the table and unfortunately for the Democratic Party, I mean
these used to be wedge issues for a reason, right? These were
concocted in think tanks with the deliberate design to make it
seem as though there was some significant disagreements between
the two parties and and they were created
to make the Republicans more popular so that people would focus
on
whatever, you know, the the Family Foundation decided was a more
successful way to to present anti-trans narratives after focus
group focus testing their their message and and when people are
focusing on that they're always going to go okay, well the Democrats
are silly. Why do they care about this? This is like a tiny sliver
of the population.
This is maybe
How would you describe the solution to this? The solution to
this
is always going to be having positive
constructive arguments for your own policies, right? If you have
your own vision for the country that you can run on, then you
never have to you could respond once, but you don't have to consistently
respond. The issue with Democrats is because of the broadness
of their coalition, the broadness of their their tent, okay?
The the the massive size of their tent and all of the blocks
the identity blocks they need to pander to. They don't have a
coherent vision. So when the Republicans are saying something,
they always want to push back against it. That's like a big thing.
There's tons of people who will want to push back against that,
right? If you constantly get baited into pushing back against
Republicans going oh, you have trans got crazy, then it looks
like you're on that side. So it's not just the perception of
like oh, Republicans are talking about it, so Dems
so so the perception is that Dems are saying it. I don't think
it's just that. I think there are a lot of Dems who will say
no no no, that's insane. No no no, that's insane. They might
even say they might not even spend time on it. They might go
well obviously that's insane and then move on. And that's what's
used as like the obvious sign that they're on the other side
of that issue.
I I don't believe that Dems were as good at at jumping over the
bait or avoiding the bait as a lot of Dem influencers want you
to believe.
Instead,
they should like every moment that they're talking about that
is a moment where they're not talking about like affordability
where where they're not talking about like a working class centered
party. >> Where are the Democrats that ran on trans issues?
Show them TO ME, PEOPLE. WHERE ARE THEY? THEY DIDN'T. NO, I AGREE.
OH, WAIT. WAIT, isn't that what Hasan is saying?
Is it Is that literally what Hasan's point is? Is that hey, there
like think tanks who presented this as Dem opinion, but it wasn't
Dem opinion?
Oh, I
Wait, what? Now, but I'm I'm sitting here and I'm like wait wait
wait wait wait. Hasan's not even taking my position.
She's hitting JoJo poses. That's why I thought she was a sassy
black woman, by the way. Okay?
it sounds like she's correcting Hasan almost. Listen. after focus
group focus testing their their message and and when people are
focusing on that they're always going to go okay, well the Democrats
are silly. Why do they care about this? This is like a tiny sliver
of the population.
Instead,
they should like every moment that they're talking about that
is a moment where they're not talking about like affordability
where where they're not talking about like a working class centered
party. >> Where are the Democrats that ran on trans issues?
Show them to me, people. >> Exactly. So she like So she
just wasn't listening. So Hasan's saying that's the perception,
right? Is that not Hasan's literally just saying
that's the perception and she went off as if
Hasan was saying the opposite of what she thinks. Yes, she No,
she was agreeing with him. Okay, hold They didn't. NO, I AGREE.
>> I AGREE. They did not. >> THE REPUBLICANS. BUT
you you you actually brought that up and I 100% agree with you.
We're That was that was his point. She just she wasn't listening.
She heard some trigger words and she wasn't paying attention
to him. She You can see she's saying okay now. She's trying to
act like she disagrees. Now I have to watch the Hutch reaction
to that. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. That should be where
we are, right? Focus group. >> Focus group focus test is
offering, you know, free billion dollar advice. It's like, you
know what? You just got to get up there and just be like none
of that matters, you know? Everybody knows this.
I'm not sure why Kamala didn't even bring him on. It turns out
the way that you deal with wedge issues that the Republican Party
pummel
into the American electorate
with insane
levels of Oh, I have to I have to go back and watch Hutch's whole
take on this section real quick. Hold on. I I really do. I really
I
I hate to go back, but I have to I have to watch for myself first
and then I have to go and watch Hutch's reaction, okay? These
used to be wedge issues for a reason, right? These were concocted
in think tanks with the deliberate design to make it seem as
though there was some significant disagreements between the two
parties
and and they were created
to make the Republicans more popular so that people would focus
on
whatever, you know, the the Family Foundation decided Hasanabi
has cracked the code, you guys. What a
He's He's literally just saying things Hutch obviously would
agree with. Oh god, I
He What does he disagree with? WHAT DO YOU DISAGREE WITH, BRO?
brilliant political mind. I'm not sure why Kamala didn't even
Hasan is about 6 months behind. In what way? Where is he 6 months
behind, your hero? Wait, hold on. Your hero right now. Go ahead.
Tell me where the narrative is. Tell me why Hasan's behind and
where the narrative is now. What is he missing?
Keep in mind, we haven't even we haven't even heard what the
answer is yet. Like we haven't heard the whole thing. I don't
believe he got cut off halfway. I We're we're waiting. We're
actually just waiting for your hero to give us the answer. On
the miss info issues, he's too busy with Israel-Palestine.
He's 6 months behind on the miss They're talking about what happened
in the 2024 election. If you're confused about why he's talking
about the 2024 election, it's because the question is about the
2024 election. That would be why he seems to be  behind.
It's because he's talking about the past. I swear to god, I want
I just want to mock Hasan's positions when he says stuff and
then I have to hear people get so hot and horny to try to criticize
this guy and fail miserably that I sit here correcting them.
That's like how the content flows. It's [__]
Can you guys just have like coherent arguments for why you might
think he's wrong on something?
And bring him on. It turns out the way that you deal with wedge
issues that the Republican Party pummel into the American electorate
with insane
levels of coordinated
to make people afraid of immigrants and trans people and the
like.
It turns out all you got to do is just get up there and say none
of that stuff is really important. It's like wedge issues are
only wedge issues if you if you entertain them. Wait, that Wait,
what does Hutch think the solution is?
That's That's not my position and I don't think I don't I don't
want to sit here talking about trans issues. Here's my That's
not my position. Here's my position, but I don't want to talk
about trans issues. I want to talk about the economy cuz the
economy is affecting everybody right now. Super easy. Or dignify
them with
That's That's what he's saying here. Just like don't you know
that they came up with the stuff in a think tank? It's all Like
everybody knows this. Of course like everybody knows this. Every
Hassan Wait, do you think Hold on. Your hero, do you think Hassan
wasn't making this point? Hassan made this point constantly during
the election. Hassan made this point all the time during the
election. What do you mean he's 6 months behind? I promise you
he made Hassan used to make this point all the time. Don't deign
any of this stuff with a response. This is an op. Don't talk
about it. Hey, when I remember it because he uses it for immigration,
too. He says, "Oh, immigration is an issue? Republicans don't
actually care about that. They allow all these illegal immigrants.
Point out that they allow the illegal immigrants in. They never
actually stop it. It never slows down under Republicans and move
on. Don't deign it with like a digni- Don't deign it with like
any substantial response. Just say those people are lying and
move on. Don't give Don't let it suck up time. Move past it."
This has been his position forever. Everybody understands that
there's coordinated propaganda pushes from right-wing media to
make people afraid of like trans people using bathrooms and stuff
like that. And Hassan's up there thinking he you know, he he's
presenting as though he's offering, you know, free billion-dollar
advice. It's like, "You know what? You just got to get up there
and just be like none of that matters, you know?" decided was
a more successful way to to present anti-trans narratives
um after focus group focus testing their their message
uh and and more when people are focusing on that, they're always
going to go, "Okay, well, the Democrats are silly. Why do they
care about this? This is like a tiny sliver of the population
uh in Kamala Harris did not run on wedge issues. This is just
a lie. The Trump tried to bait her multiple times.
Where is the lie? Hassan Hassan isn't saying that
I don't It doesn't seem to me that Hassan's saying that she ran
on them. He's saying something different. He's incorrect for
a different reason, right?
I I haven't heard him say, "Oh, Kamala's spent a bunch of time
talking about trans issues." I haven't heard him say
It's a He's talking about like an artificial wedge issue that
isn't getting responded to. Right? That's what he's saying. >> steering
away from what she was trying to center her campaign on. Is she
black? Is she Indian? She doesn't even know. She didn't take
that bait. She just On that debate stage, she just deflected
to whatever. But the idea that she was running on like identity
politics or wedge issues is ridiculous and ahistorical. Instead
Yeah, I He's saying the opposite.
He's saying the op- He's saying the
Hutch misunderstood Oh god, Hutch misunderstood, too.
Bro, I I don't understand
I don't understand I Imagine Okay, you guys have jobs, right?
Some of you guys have jobs. Imagine you had to sit there and
your job was reviewing other people who did your job of reviewing
people, right? It's this meta thing. And every time you go to
do a performance review, you see a person who earns way more
than you, who does their job infinitely worse than you at all
times. Can you imagine how much of a mind that is?
You you review people who do a job of reviewing people. It's
the same thing. And you constantly review people who do the job
so much worse than you, who are incapable of like listening and
understanding and and dealing with the hypothetical like giving
any And then you have to sit there. You have to watch them earn
so much more money than you, have such a big platform. It feels
It's such a massive mind
That happens in real jobs? Okay, Hutch probably earns five times
more than me. Maybe not. Maybe not. I I actually do okay, but
maybe not that much. But he might earn twice as much as me. It's
not like $1,000 more. It's like a lot more. said they should
like every moment that they're talking about that is a moment
where they're not talking about like affordability, where where
they're not talking about like a working-class centered party.
>> Where are the Democrats that ran on trans issues? Show
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I love her. I Look
at My god, you never see this. He They both misunderstood
and are reveling in their misunderstanding.
It's like actually just mind-blowing.
This is mind-blowing. He's never in a forum where somebody
Thank you. That Now that is the
Let it out. Like just LET IT OUT, YOU
BRO, is There's got to be There's got to be somebody here who
points out I wasn't watching his chat. Did his chat at least
point out that there's just nobody making that point?
And look at his face, too. Like he's never ever pressed in this
kind of way
when he's doing his streams. He's never pressed on this [__]
And then she Look at like she's throwing her whole body into
it, bro. >> to me. Every moment that they're talking about
that is a moment where they're not talking about like affordability,
where where they're not talking about like a working-class party.
>> Where are the Democrats that ran on trans issues? Show
them to me, PEOPLE. >> EXACTLY. EXACTLY. I AGREE. >> NO,
I AGREE. >> EXACTLY. I AGREE.
EXACTLY. I agree. Then what the [__] was your point?
Republican. >> But you you I thought his point I thought
his point was literally I His point was literally that Republicans
did this to like talk about it and make it seem provide the perception
that Democrats talk about these issues when they don't.
That's That is the point. >> You actually brought that
up and I 100% agree with you what you said. >> Sorry I
Sorry I jumped out my seat. >> Yeah. No, I I 100% agree
with you cuz you said the potholes, right? >> Like if you're
talking about the potholes and your opponent is constantly being
like, "WELL, WHAT ABOUT TRANS PEOPLE?" then they look insincere
and they look silly. And Hang on. Pause. Did he just like try
to totally switch >> Wait, okay. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Is Hutch going to go back and watch? Maybe Hutch is going
to go back and watch. Hold on. Hold on. >> this whole kind
of Hold on. Yeah, I think the >> Oh, no.
Oh, no. >> cultural stuff is only relevant if that
ostensibly the only thing that you're bringing to the table.
And unfortunately for the Democratic Party, I mean, these used
to be wedge issues for a reason, >> Unfortunately for the
Democratic Party, these used to be wedge issues for a reason.
These were He's saying that the Democrats don't have a positive
message. They don't have like a compelling positive message.
And so, what happens is Democrat pundits, Democrat people will
push back on that stuff. Not that Kamala runs on it, but they'll
push back on that stuff. And even though even though they're
not running on it, they'll say, "We're not running on it." And
and they'll just provide they'll say like, "Oh, but we don't
necessarily
He's He's saying that it's a wedge issue also because Republicans
spend all their time talking about it. It's like a artificially
inflated wedge issue. uh concocted in think tanks with the deliberate
design to make it seem as though there was some significant disagreements
between the two parties
uh and and they were created
to make the Republicans more popular so that people would focus
on
uh whatever, you know, the the Family Foundation decided was
a more successful way to to present anti-trans narratives
um after focus group focus testing their their message uh and
and more when people are focusing on that, Okay, to be fair to
Hassan, I think he is
Uh to be fair to Hutch,
it is hard to listen sometimes, okay? There's a chat. There's
like
I don't know. His nose is probably itchy or something. It is
hard to just pay attention to the video sometimes. I'll give
him that, okay? talking about the people. So just to be fair
to him, I think I had the wrong read on that that he Oh [__]
Oh [__] He went back. He went back and Listen, I
take back what I said, okay? I take I take back what I said about
him being worse at the job. He went back. He reevaluated and
he changed his opinion. That's all I want, okay? When somebody
does good, you can say, "Okay, you did good. You did good, Hutch."
Can we get claps? Claps in the chat for Hutch. I just I love
to see somebody who will actually go back and admit they were
wrong. Uh now, I will say oddly, He was He was >> oddly
very oddly, his editor, I believe, still used that as the as
the clip that he used to introduce the video. I think the cultural
stuff is only relevant if that is ostensibly the only thing that
you're bringing to the table. And unfortunately for the Democratic
Party, I mean, these used to be wedge issues for a reason, right?
When people are focusing on that, they're always going to go,
"Okay, well, the Democrats are silly. Why do they care about
this? This is like a tiny sliver of the population." Kamala Harris
did not run on wedge issues. This is just a lie. The idea that
she was running on like >> the stinger, the stinger, the
title, everything is like a total lie about this video.
So this is once again the issue with Kyle Kulinski, right? It's
the Kyle Kulinski issue rearing its ugly head again. Hutch, you
control this channel. You know you own this channel. Why don't
you get your editor to stop like straight up lying? Like this
is just straight up lying
in a way that Hutch doesn't agree with, by the way. Like uh somebody
should actually say to Hutch, "Hey, your your editor is like
lying on your on your name right now, okay? On your name."
I Now, if if hold on, cuz we could listen a little bit more.
Maybe I missed I don't think we watched the stinger originally.
We didn't watch the whole thing. Maybe it comes up then he goes,
"Oh, never mind. I was wrong." >> are wedge issues. It's
[__] ridiculous. What's the Kyle Kulinski issue?
Uh basically Hutch misrepresented Kyle Kulinski in a thumbnail
and title.
And Kyle Kulinski took issue with it.
That Hutch it wasn't being honest. And then Hutch goes, "I never
tried to be dishonest." and tried to get out of blatant dishonesty
by his editor. It was an ahistorical Like every moment that they're
talking about that is a moment where they're not talking about
like affordability, where where they're not talking about like
a working-class centered party. >> Where are the Democrats
that ran on trans issues? Show Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I love her. My God. You never see this. Thank you. That Now that
is the response. Let it out. Like just Let it out, you know?
And look at his face too. Like he's never ever pressed in this
kind of way when he's doing his streams. He's never pressed I
Dude, you're a hero. You must feel like a right now. Hutch Hutch
was able to identify his mistake. And you're still here and you're
like, "Hutch is so far ahead of us. Oh my God, Hassan's way behind."
And Hutch goes back. We watch the rest of the Hutch clip. And
Hutch goes, "Oh, never mind. I'm a
That's unfortunate for you, buddy. pressed on this Where are
they? THEY DID NO, I did it.
Exactly. I agree. This is kind of a wild panel situation. Okay.
All right. We continue. We can we can keep going. Okay, good.
Sorry I Sorry I jumped out of my seat. No, I I 100% agree with
you cuz you said the potholes, right? >> Like if you're
talking about the potholes and your opponent is constantly being
like, "WELL, WHAT ABOUT TRANS PEOPLE?" then they look insincere
and they look silly. And there's no reason to betray marginalized
groups and and decide that we're going to actively write them
out of the equation because they're working class as well. And
this is something that I have never compromised on and yet seemingly
I've been able to find like a very populist and and robust movement
in in my own audience that that does not compromise on these
issues, but also is always in the affirmative making the argument
that we have to focus on kitchen table issues, if you want to
use that kind of language around it, but like center the working
class and and try to seek out what their problems are, address
them, and also make this earnest attempt and show that we are
honest about actually fighting for them. And I think Zoran's
campaign and its success was a fantastic example of this. I know
people say it's in New York, but that's precisely what he did.
Five key issues. He went out. He asked people, "What's your problem?
I'm going to solve it." And he centered his campaign around five
key issues of affordability in New York. And lo and behold, in
spite of 22 billionaires uh spending hundreds of millions of
dollars trying to take him out, in spite of a very hostile media
environment especially uh leading up to the primary or certainly
after the primary, they they genuflected a little bit by the
end, but and and uh and all of these attack ads, he still won.
Yeah. I
I wanted to see if you guys you what No, It's your show. I want
I want to hear what I am your guest. God, this is going
Are we having fun yet? I'm having Are we having fun yet?
Okay, Jessica, I want you to respond and then I I want to kind
of tease two things out here. Well,
I agree. I I totally agree. I just exist in a world where we
can't behave that way. Like
not everybody who's going to run for office or who who wants
to have a voice can build the platform that you have. You're
ridiculously talented and
Damn, thank you. No.
No, but even being able to talk that long or to It's a skill
set that I that I don't have.
But when you say
"We don't need to deal with this." and I agree with you about
the ad and I remember when that happened.
There are people who are running in races where you need to do
more than that. Like we were talking earlier. I was overdoing
uh Tim's pod with him. We're talking about Jared Golden not running
in Maine. And Jared Golden can't
to win to not talk about the issue
Sorry, I had to walk away for a second. I'm back. Um I walked
away. I heard Hassan say basically exactly what my point was
on the Mondani thing. You remember we heard Sneako and Azan Gold
from the right argue that Mondani should have actually stood
on business on Israel and said like, "No, Israel's like a genocidal
regime. America first. We don't want to support Israel at all."
Right? That's And it's like, "No. Don't talk about Israel. You're
a New York mayoral mayoral candidate. Don't talk about Israel
at all. Shut the [__] up about Israel. Focus on the
actual issues in your city." And he did that and he won. And
as Hassan pointed out,
I'm psyched that Hassan's on my side on that one. That's the
position we talked about at length, you know, dealing with right-wing
critiques. I thought maybe Hassan would think about it from the
other perspective, right? Like, "Oh, he should actually stand
up business on Israel." But he didn't. You love to see it. issues
that his constituents genuinely care about because they also
vote for Donald Trump. And for some of them they just want to
hear someone say, "Listen, I want to protect everybody. I'm an
inclusive guy, you know, but I
whatever happened with Leah Thomas or that's always like the
lightning rod, you know, trans athlete issue. I understand your
concern about, you know, trans women in women's sports. That
doesn't mean Jared Golden needs to say I want a ban on this.
It means Jared Golden says, like the head of the NCAA did when
they testified, they said you're talking about 10 athletes out
of
So it is a small fraction of the population, but I'm not going
to dismiss your concerns."
And this big tent and a winning coalition
across this country
has to be compromising about what people need to do to win their
races. I'm not talking about being bigoted. I'm not talking about
being nasty.
But
Hold on. I'm not talking about bigoted or being nasty. I'm just
talking about
total total pro-life candidates in Alabama if it means you could
win a house district.
It's like, "Okay." But I think, you know, I can't call it bigotry,
but
It's not a part of your values at all.
The country operates differently in different places. And I feel
like we give lip service to that, but don't always behave that
way. I It Like
The thing is like if the Democratic Party was defined
by
five key policies, okay? Medicare for Uh a single-payer system,
socialized medicine, right? Something of that sort. Um and and
a a plan to expand the available housing uh units. I I want socialized
housing. That is not even broached. That's not even discussed
amongst the Democratic Party. I want a a federal jobs guarantee
and a and a jobs program to build those houses, right? Uh free
college and and better education overall from K through 12. If
those were like your five key signature campaign promises that
directly tackle all of the the issues that people the economic
hardships that people in the heartland are actually
Socialized housing is maybe a bad name for it. I don't know why
he wouldn't just say like grants for like literally just housing
starts is the only thing you should optimize for.
Like literally just housing starts. That's it. However, I you
subsidize people like starting houses. You make it so that it's
slightly less You you can't ever make it so it's like profitable
to just do housing starts and abandon them, but literally just
make it so somebody has to put in money to start building a house.
And the second somebody starts building a house,
you want China's housing. I think you'd be way smarter than how
China does it and I think the American government's perfectly
capable. It's just like socialized housing is
at least like the projects in most major cities are just like
the worst example. I think it's like gone pretty badly in a lot
of cases. they're going through and not just like uh you know,
highly educated liberals in big cities, then any moment that
these people would turn around and be like, "Well, what about
trans people? They're going to get health care too." You could
just be like, "Okay. What? Do you not want health care because
you think a trans person is going to get it?" >> just want
to be clear. There was a moment on the debate stage where where
they weren't talking about trans people, but in the Democratic
primary in 2020 they asked There was a one of the large primary
debates and they asked, "Well, do you think undocumented people
should have health care?" And people raised their hand and it
was used as an attack ad. And it wasn't effective attack ad.
So I think sometimes we I I agree with some of what you're saying,
okay? The dig at small businesses I disagree with because the
biggest driver of wealth in in in African-American communities
outside of government jobs, which is why the fact that 300,000
black women have lost their government jobs is a blow to like
wealth ascension in this country for black women, is small businesses.
And so the small business plan was a plan that spoke to working
class black and brown people in this country who do not work
at large corporations but had an idea wanted entrepreneurship
and then they they saw a plan for them and so it was a wide a
wide you know tent situation. But I guess my point is to Jessica
what Jessica's saying yes I do think candidates have to be you
got to run for your district. You got to run for the race that
you're in.
As a as a you know I'm I'm I'm a black woman from the Midwest
every day everywhere I go, okay? I live in Washington DC but
I'm I'm I'm black and I'm bald.
So there are some things I think I hear when I when these conversations
come up and I've sat in strategist rooms when they've come up.
They've come up on campaigns I've worked on and I hear them on
the on the sets in the commercial breaks of when we have some
of these candidates on our show.
It feels like to some people that look like me that the people
within the party apparatus want folks to compromise on issues
that that that for for me are not are uncompromisable.
When folks Okay. She's just she's literally just defined why
the abundacrat thing is stupid.
Congratulations.
You just you just actually said you don't believe in the Ezra
Klein thing. You're you're stating a principle that stops you
from believing the Ezra Klein thing. Cuz guess what? To make
those that's how your party runs now is there are things that
are uncompromisable. Like segregation desegregation
or sorry segregation not desegregation. Segregation something
you wouldn't you wouldn't ever go and frown with, right?
why would pro-life pro-choice why would why would like autonomy
for women's bodies like bodily autonomy why would that be something
you could frown with? There are tons of people where that's a
red line.
Right? I don't I can't think of the other there are a couple
that are like major red line situations.
But I I just don't have any idea why she thinks that's that's
you've just described the principle that stops a lot of people
from going with the the Ezra Klein abundance oh we need to run
pro-life Dems again. Segregation is a red line. I'm talking about
it in the geopolitical sense not in the African-American racism
you know economic uh what would you call prejudice sense, okay?
Stop. Folks say that and so like I do think that if the party
is like look people need to
I think the answer is people need to run for the race that they're
in. Okay, well what does that mean? Does that mean when because
let's be VERY CLEAR DONALD TRUMP AND THE Republicans they aren't
they aren't looking for a big tent. They're like mass deportation
F you look at my one good black person.
all the brown people need to be deported. Women got blood coming
down their eyes but like yay uh we're going back to a meritocracy
and that means only white men. LIKE WHAT ARE WHAT HOLD ON WHAT?
Dude her her her like
Are those really her big issues? Alien mode so I'm saying abundacrat
cuz it's just a thing to refer to the Ezra Klein people, okay?
So as people there are a lot of people who pro who like I guess
would shill for Ezra Klein's beliefs the things he talked about
in the book but also things he talks about after the book. And
one of the things he's been talking about when he goes around
and talks about the book and about how where does he see America
going is he says well we need to run candidates who run for like
their districts and are willing to take on issues or or take
unpopular national take on take positions unpopular for national
Democrats that are popular in their district. So something like
being a pro-life Dem if you run in Alabama, right? You can't
run as a pro-choice Dem in Alabama. You you straight up won't
win ever. So that's it's an Ezra Klein thing it's like a a thing
that's being attributed to him. So the pro-life yep that's where
that discussion came from. Yes. That's why I'm talking about
Ezra Klein here. But they're win but they were winning. I kind
of have to go back with this person again. I think
she like doesn't follow her own principle to the end of the sentence
somehow. black person [__] countries in Africa all
the brown She's like she's mad about this stuff and it's like
dude I'm sure a lot of feminists would feel equally bad about
the concept of running somebody who's pro-life.
Yeah? brown people need to be deported. Women got blood coming
down their eyes but like yay uh we're going back to a meritocracy
and that means only white men. LIKE WHAT ARE WHAT HOLD ON WHAT?
But they're win but they were winning. And so they didn't win
because they opened up the aperture and let people do what they
need to do they want because they tripled down on what they believe.
>> I'm just not right. That's just not I'm sorry. That
sounds good and I like it I want it to be right it's just not
right. They didn't they didn't win because they tripled down
on what they believe? No they did triple down on what they Yes
they tripled down on racism.
They dipped it a little Tim's going to say now I think there's
more nuance to it being perfectly wrong or perfectly correct.
Absolutely there's a lot of people who when you double down on
on something like racism they just go that's awesome. I love
that you're like authentic that you're real even if they're not
particularly racist themselves they might like that in some way,
okay? So I don't think she's totally wrong.
there's also a group of people
there's also I don't think anyone here could be totally right
or wrong. There's definitely also a group of people who are just
like racist and tripling down on that would be like awesome for
them. Especially in the rural places, okay? Any any largely rural
state I'm sorry it's going to that's going to work out. It was
populism but it was a it's if he was a Populism is a thin ideology
mixed with a thick ideology according to Cas Mudde. Simon His
populism the does that mean? I hate that. She just did that's
like that's like erudite coded right there, right? What she just
did?
She just did a reference to like some book some thinker
and gave no explanation for what that means. It's a thin ideology
paired with a thick ideology. What the are you saying? a little
with dipped it a little it was it was populism but it was a it's
if he was a Populism is a thin ideology mixed with a thick ideology
according to Cas Mudde. Simon His populism was a little it had
a lot of things in it was an economic populist but populism had
a little white supremacy in it a little racism. Like Bernie Sanders
is a populist in a different way than Donald >> Yeah this
here's the thing >> So I don't understand. Tim a black
woman is speaking sit your white ass down and listen. Don't try
to get a word in edgewise. What are you doing? No here's the
thing though can I just say really quick though here's the thing
like yeah he doubled down on a bunch of Here's America America's
racial hierarchy, okay? America's identity hierarchy, okay? Black
woman up at the top. White man somewhere near the bottom. Absolute
Turkish propagandist communist, okay? Turkish communist I should
say. Turkish communist, okay? Right at the bottom. Shut the [__]
up Hasan a white man is speaking. It's a terrible [__]
that they believe it's extreme. No doubt. No doubt. He also was
seen as left of Kamala on foreign policy. He was seen as an anti-war
candidate. He was seen as anti the Republican establishment of
war. He cut to the middle on that. Yeah he lied about that for
sure. >> The first THING HE WAS WAS OKAY BUT THEN WHAT
THEN MAYBE OUR GUYS SHOULD LIE about some things that are popular,
too.
Is Tim is Tim like democracy is failed
Tim doesn't believe in democracy either. That's so based, okay?
Thank you. I mean don't not really thank you that's like horrifying
but listen.
The thing about lying is lying begets lying, right? If you lie
about something you start having to lie about a whole bunch of
other things and you start to be incoherent and then it's just
like the funniest coolest person gets to win. And in politics
it was all nerds and for a long time the funniest and coolest
person was Donald Trump somehow.
We'll see if that starts I think that's going to start changing
but you don't want to make it's going to be a whole totally different
kind of person. If you're some sort of technocrat you cannot
run on the oh we should just lie position. I don't think I don't
think it works if you're a technocrat which I assume Tim is if
he runs like a leftist channel. Although the bullwark am I crazy
or was the bullwark's concept like right-wing people or people
who are formerly right-wing who go to the left. Tim that's Tim,
right? That he used to be like a right-winger a
and he moves over to the left over time. No Tim I thought Tim
was left. I thought he was like a like a Democrat now. Is he
just like a never Trumper?
It's the never Trumpers no. Oh is he just he's just a never Trumper?
Oh cool. All right.
Well based. Why sorry I just assumed he was a Democrat cuz he
said he straight up said we maybe some of our guys should
He's a gay right-winger. Well it seems like he's going further
left now.
Dude I don't know.
Wait this no. You sound like me during the campaign where I was
like what the are you guys doing when you're not like addressing
this stuff where Donald Trump can present himself as the peace
candidate. That was insane to me. But obviously sending Bill
Clinton to Dearborn to talk about Judea and Samaria as most people
were seeing All right.
most people were seeing I want to bring US BACK. >> THEY
DIDN'T moderate on things. That's all I'm saying.
having SO MUCH FUN. NO NO. I'M SORRY YOU CANNOT have a convention
where you have signs that say mass deportation now. I'm not saying
he was a moderate I'm saying he moderated on
I maybe I like this Tim Miller guy. Maybe this guy maybe this
is my guy.
he's just saying he's saying a lot of correct things. Not always
correct things but he's saying a lot of correct things. How is
it hard to understand that Trump was able to get voters by moderating
on certain issues,
That's not even confusing this is obviously true. on things >> ethnocentric
nationalist version of this country and SAY THAT HE MODERATED.
WHAT HE DID Yes you can. You can if you just cut it down.
Right? He moderated on certain issues. That means if you just
want to take the
that means on at least one issue
he moderated. He went more towards the center of the country.
That's objectively true.
And she's like sewing out for no reason. YOU CAN'T SAY HE MODERATED
WHEN HE'S A WHITE SUPREMACIST. Actually they could literally
be running Nick Fuentes and Nick Fuentes could change on some
things and you could say he moderated on some
You you could you can literally say this. Yes. >> It is
saying, "People in Gaza, you should vote for me because Joe Biden
didn't do away with what you want." That's not A MODERATION.
HE HAD GOOD RHETORIC, BUT HIS POLICY was consistent. And the
Vice President on that debate stage said all of the things that
he was saying that he would do and he has now done them. HE SAID
HE WAS GOING to send the military into the streets. He was saying
it on the campaign. That's not moderation. That's fascism. I
agree with you. He was going to deport all of these people in
this country. >> I agree. That is what He said that it's
not just the criminals. He's coming for anybody that is in this
country who was undocumented. So, I'm I just I can't I I can't
get with the Well, Donald Trump did moderate A BIT. NO. THEY
TRIPLED DOWN ON THE bad stuff and had nice graphics and good
and and and smile through it. So, can I Just that uh Tim's just
winning. God, I don't know. I might I'm not I'm not joking. I
I'm thinking about just watching Hutch for the rest of this cuz
I I now I find myself watching these things and I'm trying to
figure out where Hutch would go on some of these things. Hutch
has got to be on Tim's side here. You know what? I'm actually
not going to go. I'm going to say I've pondered the orb. Hutch
is on Tim's side as well. Everybody's looking at this Simone
Sanders person and going, is she okay? Is is she okay? She all
right? Yeah, I want to bring us back.
All right. Hassan quick Hassan, do not say Simone is correct.
Do not say Sim-
He's going to try to Listen, Hassan believes this is where Hassan's
identity politics kick in, okay? This is where they kick in cuz
Hassan's going to go He's going to try to do the benevolent misogyny
thing where he's going to go, "Oh, she's got a point." And this
is like the point she has. She doesn't have a point. She's saying
something totally right now. And Hassan's going to go and try
to save her cuz he just like that. And then I want to bring us
back. Simone is absolutely right, 100%. And these were things
that I was screaming about non-stop. You said you were agreeing
with me that he ran to the left of Kamala on foreign policy.
On foreign policy. That's moderating. It's It's very obvious
where the disconnect is. Why is the moderator not stepping in?
Is this moderator farming content?
Cuz it's Hey, one of you is saying in a small subset of places
Trump moderated while becoming more extreme in other places.
You both would agree on that. Simone is maybe not understanding.
I think Tim understands. On foreign policy. However, however,
he didn't run on the unpopular Republican views on foreign policy.
He ran to the left on foreign policy only because the Democrats
came out and said, "I'm going to have the most lethal military
because on foreign Oh, God.
Don't don't pivot to Israel, please. Please don't pivot to Israel.
But, Hassan Hassan, please don't pivot to Israel. Don't pivot
to Israel. Don't pivot to Israel. Please. Please. >> Fortunately,
they and I'm I mean this sincerely, I don't think the Democrats
actually saw the threat of Donald Trump as a significant enough
threat because if they were, they would have locked in and and
had better messaging overall and tried to at least establish
a base of support with counter narrative with counter messaging
leading up to the election, not in the after Okay. Okay. Okay.
He Hey, he just said something that's okay. Thank you math. Or
not during the election, but leading up to the election because
Republicans, they act as though there is an election every single
day. They are constantly on message. They're constantly creating
an alternative reality with lies saying that undocumented migrants
are actually responsible for a metric ton of the crimes that
are taking place in American cities when that is a abject lie,
okay? And when I talk to congresspersons,
whether it be at the DNC or even before even after, and I tell
them, "Why the [__] aren't you guys
Trump ran left on foreign policy.
Um the way they're going to say that, check it up, is Trump consistently
ran on like, "I'm going to get peace in all these places. I don't
want any new wars. We don't want to have the military engaging
anywhere." And he just lied, right? He just lied that hey, the
US isn't going to engage anywhere else. We're just going to like
keep our military basically at home and and if people get if
people get rowdy, we'll do something, but otherwise we're not
going to do anything else, right? That's He just lied. Yes.
It's counter messaging against the He lied and there's probably
like pretty good reason to believe he lied.
Yeah. We are a nation of immigrants. America is the most diverse
nation on the [__] planet. It is literally the reason
why we are such a domineering force beyond all these other beyond
all the other, you know, violent reasons, but
but like that is what That is one of the most redeemable aspects
of America that I personally love that the Democrats completely
dropped because they were scared. They saw that one poll from
the Pew Center of Research that said that said that 66% of Americans
want mass deportations. That exact same poll also showed that
if given two options, mass deportation and mass amnesty, that
the majority always chose mass amnesty. So, why is that never
communicated? Because Americans, sure, the median voter trying
to understand where the median voter is coming from is impossible,
okay? You will yourself if you try to understand what these people
are thinking. >> me, Hassan. I was with you halfway through
that, but you lost me. But, I'm I'm with you. >> but what
I'm trying to say is this. Wait, what?
Why does she keep saying nothing? She talks This lady hasn't
said sh- This lady talks a lot and has said literally nothing
this whole time. Has only ever been wrong in the things she says.
Okay? There are Trump supporters out there, okay? That that have
have been diluted into thinking that Donald Trump represented
a change. And obviously, we saw that buyer's remorse this past
Tuesday, right? Especially in Hispanic communities where they
were like, "Oh, I can't believe that he is actually doing mass
deportation." And and it's it's you know, we're in DC. This is
a fairly liberal crowd and we laugh at those people, but like
I talk to those people every day. And there were people that
genuinely thought They genuinely believed that Donald Trump was
actually exorcising the the the violent criminals. And the only
reason why people are led to believe this lie aside from the
faucet of misinformation that comes from independent outlets
on the right and also Fox News as well is because So, Hassan's
about to say something that would trigger the [__]
out of Hutch right here, okay? This is going to trigger the [__]
out of Hutch cuz he's going to say it's both sidesing
Hassan should be better about messaging this. He's going to say,
"Listen, I have an issue with how Dems message on this, okay?
It's it's an issue. I will say obviously, the bigger problem
is the Republicans, but I can't control that.
because I can't control that, I'm going to focus on something
I can't control, which is Hey, these Dems are are are going to
get um or sorry, these Dems I have a problem with their messaging
on illegal immigration. Give me a
Uh amnesty
right here. showed that if given two options, mass deportation
and mass amnesty, I might skip forward. trying to say is this,
okay? There are Trump supporters out there, okay? That that have
have been diluted into thinking that Donald Trump represented
a change. And obviously, we saw that buyer's remorse this past
Tuesday, right? Especially in Hispanic communities where they
were like, "Oh, I can't believe that he is actually doing mass
deportation." And and it's it's you know, we're in DC. This is
a fairly liberal crowd and we laugh at those people, but like
I talk to those people every day. And there were people that
Jared. It's come on, Hassan. Come on, Cap. Can we get some caps?
Can we get some Can we get some caps spend spend in the chat?
He talks to those people every day. No, you don't. No, YOU DON'T.
I KNOW FOR A FACT YOU DON'T TALK to people every day cuz you
stream like 7-8 hours a day. I know you don't talk to those people
every day. Shut the [__] up.
God, why's he got to lie about that? That's like such a crazy
lie for no reason. genuinely thought They genuinely >> Well,
sorry. It's a crazy like cope for no reason. believed
that Donald Trump was actually exorcising the the the violent
criminals. And the only reason why people are led to believe
this lie aside from I'm calling flowchart flowchart flowchart.
I'm preemptively calling a flowchart in 5 4 3 the faucet
I mean, it's not hard to call. That's literally That exact this
lead up right here is what me go maybe go, "I need to switch
over to Hutch." Hutch is going to be very mad about this. Hutch
is going to be very angry that Hassan's going to criticize Democrats
here. of misinformation that comes from independent outlets on
the right and also Fox News as well is because there Now, Hutch
has to understand
that the flowchart him saying flowchart is automatically wrong
here because Hassan already has said very bad things happen from
Republicans, right?
Like you can't flowchart after he goes, "I'm going to acknowledge
that Republicans do a bunch of bad sh- all uh any independent
right-wing media outlets are bad. Fox News, bad.
So, he's Hutch is already lost in the flowchart point, but now
I think he's going to go to Well, Hassan's going to say something
bad about Dems and pretend that that was the flowchart point.
But, I just want you to understand he's wrong already before
he started into whatever the next point is from Hassan. There's
no robust response from the Democratic Party that said flowchart.
That's a lie. That's a lie. Undocumented They do. They do call
out the lies. They do. They They already do this.
migrants in this country are responsible
At some point, you have to give the voters agency, okay? Um I
I think this is a classic Hassan talking point. He did it during
the election a
I don't think he's wrong. I don't I don't know how to say it.
I don't think he's wrong.
I think there is but I I also Sorry, I don't think he's wrong
in his estimation of what Democrats did so much. What I think
he's wrong on is the fact that that was a bad choice.
Right? I think that was a bad I think it was a good choice, actually.
I think it was a good choice to not sit there because that's
the other wedge issue that Hassan's talking about that they're
trying to manufacture. They're going to go, "Dems love Dems love
all immigration. Look, they're going to defend illegal immigrants
all the time. Look at them defending illegal immigrants. Illegal
immigrants are taking your jobs and Dems will defend them all
the time."
And Hasan's shocked that the Dems don't want to take the bait
on that issue. The issue they're the least popular on. The maybe
the issue that hurts them the most that they differentiate from
Republicans on or try to and try to they tried to move back to
the center on immigration for this election, right? And they
have since been moving back towards They've been drifting back
to the center on
So, I think Hasan's actually wrong in his estimation of what
Democrats should have done with this. I think ignoring it or
not taking the bait on this a lot was the was a good choice.
He's saying that what you should do is every time Republicans
say that you should call them out and go, "Actually, illegal
immigrants don't commit crime. They're some of the best citizens
we have. We should have more of these people. These people are
amazing." Right? That's basically what Hasan's saying. What they
needed to counter message on was economic policy. Maybe, but
I'm I'm telling you that that Hasan's actually arguing for something
here that I disagree with entirely, but
I don't know. So, I I agree with them that that's what Dems did.
I disagree that it's wrong. I I just disagree.
At some point, you have to say
they heard that pitch and they thought Donald Trump's pitch is
better and that was their choice. But, it's not like she
press how important immigrate immigrants
Who Oh, I actually disagree. I thought I Maybe Listen, Hutch
did watch a lot of Kamala stuff, I assume.
I I thought this was intentional strategy from the Democrats
that they backed away from immigration like defending immigrants
as hard. I think they did soy a little bit. At least Kamala might
have soyed a little bit. They didn't even go that hard on they're
eating the dogs, they're eating the cats, right? I don't think
they went that hard on that. They did it like once at a rally
when it happened and then I think they dropped it entirely.
And I would say if we were going to define, you know, if we're
going to complain about messaging, we should probably define
it a little bit or get like something more narrow knocked down.
So, I'd say in my mind when you're talking about
about I'd say what Kamala covered from day to day at rallies.
That's probably more what I'm talking about.
Like the DNA of America. She did. Democrats do. They're like,
"Well, they didn't do it enough or they didn't do it aggressively."
And then they go And then you get into like Green Lantern stuff.
It's like at the end of the day like the voters hear the different
pitches and based on their own level of being in how much they're
informed or intelligent they are or whatever, they make their
choice and they decided that mass deportations was preferable
to a pathway to citizenship.
They had those two choices between those two things. They picked
Donald Trump. That was their choice. for a lower rate of per
capita crime than natural born US citizens are. If you pair that
up with documented migrants, it's negligible. It is marginal
and they're hyper focusing on it specifically because this is
a vulnerable population that is easy to target and it's easy
to ridicule and there is not enough of a robust defense mechanism
out there and that's the reason why people end up believing this
and then they get shocked when it's actually implemented. So,
I I think that's a good point and I
and I
and I think I sort of agree Love it. You're smarter than this,
buddy. I know love it. I know I I just
Like you can disagree on
on how they message. I I was under the impression they backed
away from supporting immigrants like softly. Obviously, if you
get asked like about illegal immigrants, Kamala Harris is never
going to go, "Oh, those filthy criminals." She's not going to
do that, right? But, there's a difference. There's a There's
a switch up from where they used to in 2020 and probably 2016,
probably a little bit before that even. They go, "No, these people
are These people are not a problem. They're actually part of
the strength of America. They're a part of the core strength
of the country. They're incredibly important." I just don't think
that was the messaging. I think they knew they wanted to get
away from that messaging. They knew that that was going to be
used against them and I think they did shift away from it. Oh,
he's smarter than this. The pod guys are disappointingly lately.
What's up? I know love it is smarter than this. So, >> Tim
Allen. How does he unpack this? Shock. Like this is all virtue
signals, you know, like why doesn't anyone say that immigrants
aren't that dangerous? What's going on here? Why aren't the Democrats
They They do do this. I mean, it's more complicated than that.
It's easier to make someone afraid of immigrants than it is to
convince them that they're not that that they're not dangerous.
It's just easier. It's easy. They've been disappointing.
Oh, the pod guys. Okay, the pods have guys.
They're caving to the clout.
I Dude, why aren't they
I I always say things like why aren't people doing what they
should do. I probably should just get on the I need to stop feeling
shocked about this. I feel like consistently disappointed seeing
how viewers just like buy whatever the streamer says. They don't
really pay attention. They buy whatever the streamer says. It's
probably true for my viewers. I just need to keep beyond board
with like Yeah, nobody really wants something good. They just
They want to be told what they already think. And tap into more
visceral emotions, fear, anger. It's easier to do that. And Hasan,
he he acts as though it's like Why doesn't You know what he needs
to do, man? He needs to put his money where his mouth is, bro.
Somebody's got to jump on this. Clip this, send it to I don't
know, Ethan Klein, whoever. Like we need to raise some funds
and we need to put Hasan to the test. We need to send him into
West Virginia to do a town hall. We need to send him into Missouri
to do a town like What? I What? You bore. >> Why Why would
this work?
Huh. On Hold on. On the prospect of, you know, raising funds,
guys. The prospect of raising funds. I would
to propose that you guys help me raise funds as Chatty Nickel
44 just did, okay? If you guys want to donate to the stream,
you want to make the stream go longer, we have a little donation
bar up there at the top of the screen, all right? If you observe
it, you can donate subs, you can you can gift subs, all right?
You can donate through the TTS mechanisms. Exclamation point
donate in the chat. You can give money. You can add more time
to the stream. We appreciate all donations.
I've been watching the Hutch thing the whole time. No, oaker
boy. We've not been watching it the whole time. We've gone back
when I know that there's going to be a Hutch soy soy fest coming
on. I do go and watch it. We did find out that Hutch's entire
stinger for this is fake. It's totally like made up. He basically
His editor is straight up lying about what the content of this
stream was, what the content of what Hasan said was. So, Hutch
like soys the [__] out about some point Hasan made.
He doesn't understand that he was wrong. He eventually goes back
and corrects himself, but the soy out and accompanying reaction
and stuff from the chat is what's used as the stinger for the
video, the opening. And the title says the same thing. But, then
Hutch goes back 30 seconds later and realizes he was wrong about
all of it. Yeah. So, that's that's where we're at. I just I click
back to Hutch every once in a while cuz I know he's going to
soy the [__] out of his stuff.
Ryle and Alien Mode, thank you for the gifted subs.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank
Got 2 hours left on the stream. Three subs in
I think we're maybe four subs away from another hour on the stream
right now, guys. Four subs away. Let's continue on. Like a literal
town hall with, you know, 200 Missourian voters or 200 like Arkansanian.
I don't know how you say Arkansans. We need to send him into
the deep south, Mississippi.
Rent a venue. 200 people, 400 people. I don't know. You attract
them with some kind of incentive, you know, free snacks or dinners.
I don't know what you do. And then he can go in there and he
can try this messaging on those crowds of people. He can He can
He can say what he's saying right now and if it's that easy to
just change people's minds, we should see some kind of results
there, right? Camera's going to pan
I mean, this is a really easy hypothetical test, right? Do you
should you lie? This is just should you lie?
Either Hutch needs to disagree with Hasan here and say he he
thinks those are those are wrong or that they're not even the
best response to this question. If you objectively think that
illegal immigrants are some of your most productive citizens,
some of your safest citizens, the least crime the least um at
risk of committing crimes and stuff. You think they're some of
your best people, shouldn't you say that if they're being attacked?
Isn't it like incumbent on you to protect the people who are
like your most vulnerable populations?
Isn't that a core like left center left belief? Should you Should
you just lie?
If you can't win on the things you believe, shouldn't you just
admit that hey, maybe we need to rethink this whole party. Maybe
we're just wrong.
What I think reality is, maybe I should leave politics. What
I think reality is can't be communicated to people. I've
I don't know.
I tend I tend to just think the liars win, so. >> pan out
to the crowd and speaking of people people that are like, you
know, with like
several decades of deeply ingrained cultural kind of beliefs
and political beliefs and camera's going to pan out to the crowd
and they're going to be like, "You know what?
He's right. I never thought of it that way. Wow, I'm looking
at things so differently. I'm going to go buy a $20 hammer and
sickle shirt." Like just do it, you know, like it doesn't need
to come from politicians, right? Just go do it, you know, like
if it's that easy to change people's minds. I've been telling
the Democrats for years, you know, just tell them like illegal
immigrants are not that dangerous. That's all you got to do.
Chat mixing thing you told me was right so you're right on that
already. Do it, you know? And then you can do you can do like
a survey of before and after and we can see how many, you know,
how many times people have Sorry, I just letting Cherry know
that I I Cherry told me hey, you should stop mixing your chat
cuz you're going to get suspended cuz we saw another person get
suspended and then I left the chat on the screen today and then
I got suspended. So, I'm just letting her know preemptively she's
right. She was right. I should have gotten rid of the chat.
[__] Do like a survey of before and after and we
can see how many, you know, how many times people have changed
their minds. Progressives have done this. I took Bernie into
the deep Trump country. Can he win them Can he win them over?
Well, I know that he's done um like it's one thing to send Bernie
into a crowd into like People keep talking about like a Bernie
went to West Virginia and they filled out a you know an an arena.
>> Does he really think politics works this way? No, no,
no. He doesn't think this will be effective, Destin Suggs. He
thinks that Hasan will realize that you can't go to like Alabama
or Mississippi and just tell people that like like what the truth
is and then those people will be like, "Oh, I didn't even realize."
and then they just support you. That's what he's trying to say.
And with 2,000 people it's like, well, how what percentage of
those do you think are like, you know, liberals that that came
in from the from a major city? Are we really suggesting that
Bernie and AOC are making a lot of headway in like changing political
demographics and I think I think Bernie could make a lot of headway
if he spent a lot of time campaigning the same way like Trump
did. I think Bernie made incredible headway for his movement
when he first
I think by the time he campaigned the second time, he was sort
of like by by all the Oppo like ads, research that got done into
him. I think he got kind of was just being the communist guy.
But I I think Bernie made a ton of
It just wasn't enough like unfortunately making a ton of headway
is not enough to make a dent in a in an R plus 40 place,
Like you're completely in Alabama or Mississippi. The fact that
Bernie can change the minds of anybody who hears it is going
to take It's going to be years before he makes significant headway
that changes elections.
In West Virginia? It doesn't even need to come from politicians
either. There's nothing stopping like the entire progressive
media ecosystem. They could all get together. They could build
an organization.
They could get plenty of crowdfunding for these projects. And
they can just surgically target, you know, one district at a
time each election cycle. They can That seems like it'd be a
good idea.
Dude, why don't Some political influencers should do that. Man,
if you were like a true believer in socialism, if you were like
Imagine the like
the first American Aliyah into Alabama, okay? They're picking
like one district in one city where a bunch of people who aren't
like aren't like soy leftist. They're like real leftist. They're
like working class socialism leftist who are going to go like
run farms in a community somewhere in a in rural
And they're going to work hard. They're going to integrate with
the community and try to spread their values.
This dude, it's it was it was That's a great idea. Hutch just
came up with a great idea. Not quite the way he's talking about
it, but not with like money from the outside. No, integrating
into that community, trying to build your values up there. That
would be I think that would pay dividends to be honest with you,
but
I'm not sure. I'm not sure if anybody's willing to do that. They
can go into deep red districts. They can make the pitch to voters
directly themselves. It doesn't need to come from politicians.
Hasan [__] has a bigger platform than like 90% of
Congress. Well, 75% of Congress. They can just do that. They
don't need to wait for anybody to make these pitches. Send Vanguard
into West
and he can tell them that their fear is irrational and you know,
whatever. Why does it have to come from the Democratic Party?
Like they could do that today if they wanted to. I think that's
a good point and I
and I
and I think I've sort of So, Hutch's answer was actually Kamala
did run on that, but why do you why are you even saying the Dems
need to run on that? Kamala did run on that. So, you're wrong,
but also why would that even be a good idea? So, you're wrong.
He like both sides that himself, didn't he? He was like, "No,
Kamala totally did run on protecting immigrants. She loved immigrants.
Also, you're wrong. Why don't you go do this messaging, Hasan?
It doesn't even work." He he did like both sides of it there,
did he not? I feel like he did.
I agree with Tim and with Simone ABOUT
BECAUSE BECAUSE ONE OF TRUMP'S gifts One of Trump's gifts is
he is a he he I think he convinced a lot of people he was going
to go after criminals, but he also said at the convention that
they were going to do mass deportations. And I think how to bring
it back is
that is possible because of a big void. So, Trump can do a lot
Trump has room to operate, to maneuver. Why? Because he has built
an authentic connection with millions of people who believe him,
who have his back, who think, "Yeah, he'll compromise." It is
inconceivable that Kamala Harris would appoint Mike Pence to
be Secretary of Health and Human Services. Inconceivable. We
wouldn't live in that world. But Trump can appoint a Kennedy
to run the health department. Why? Because he has built such
a credible, loyal following
that he because of the authentic way in which he you don't agree
with that. Cult. No, it's just cult.
You get Yes, it has certainly become a cult, right? And then
you look at our side and you find the politicians that have that
kind of authentic connection to the voters. You look at the list
of leadership of the Democratic Party. How far down do you go
before you have somebody that can fill a an arena? You have to
get to to Bernie Sanders, you go to Barack Obama. You have to
you go to Zoran Mamdani, you go to AOC. It is largely on the
left. That is a That is the truth of this moment, but it wasn't
always true. Barack Obama didn't run from the left. He ran against
Washington. Bill Clinton had that kind of momentum. He actually
ran from the right, but right now that energy and connection
is coming from the left. And so, Hasan lays out a group of policies
that are from the left. Like I'm not for socialized housing.
I'm for building a ton of housing. Boo. That's okay. But but
it is a void that the left is currently filling that the that
the the leadership of the Democratic Party is
I just think the history of socialized housing in America is
so bleak. I just I don't know I don't know how you justify it
in America. Like just the The story of socialized housing to
me is the story of the projects and it's just like, "Oh, this
is like the worst thing in all of
Guys, we should do the worst thing in all of America again. Nobody's
going to run on that. I I don't think you can Man, running on
that would be tough. That's a >> How does Trump get away
with all this stuff? How do we get defined as being anti-trans?
The other day Bernie Sanders was asked about the border and he
said, "Our country's got to have a border." And that pissed off
some people on >> It pissed off some people on the It pissed
you off to say that countries have to have a border? Yeah, take
that I don't think socialized housing is always awful policy.
I think you could have like socialized housing in a way that
But it I haven't seen it work very well. Okay. I Ah, that's tough.
message into the heart There's like a There's like a fact of
life where socialized house housing is meant to be for people
who are at the worst levels of poverty, right? And it just so
happens to be the case that the people at the worst level of
of poverty
tend to also be some of the worst
That's un That's something that socialist leftist can never grapple
with, okay? The people who are at the lowest levels of poverty,
the most like tread on people in society. They tend to be some
of the worst people. They can't take care of the housing they
live in. They will damage, they will harm, they will they will
slowly degrade anywhere they're contained and it takes while
like a long time to integrate those people back into society.
I'm not going to say they're like born bad. They're not born
bad in any way, but when you live in abject poverty for your
whole life, you actually don't learn the skills required to upkeep
homes and to to like be respectful of what it costs to build
a home or to take care of a home. You just don't have these values
instilled and it takes a long time to build that up and understand
that other people are taking like they're spending hours a week
working to give taxes to the government so the government can
build your house and you you get you get totally disconnected
from the amount of work that went into build your house.
Poor people equals bad. Poor people
uncivilized savages, okay? You wouldn't get somebody from like
the 1200s and put them in Well, maybe you would. I don't know.
There's just like there's a lack of There's a lack of understanding
that is difficult to overcome and I don't really judge poor people
for it. I just think it's there and it's difficult to deal with
and the the lack of acknowledgement of it is what leads a lot
of socialist projects to fail.
part of Appalachia.
You know, take that message into border into border cities in
Texas and uh Arizona and New Mexico. Or it's not poor equals
bad. It's poor equals higher proclivity to be raised without
certain values that make you function well in a society in like
the the economic reality of America.
That's it That just happens to be true and it might not be that
all the poor people are bad. Actually, sorry. It's definitely
not that all the poor people are bad. It's that poor people will
on on balance tend to be people who can't take care of things
or don't value things that cost money anywhere near as much as
people who have to work for
Just facts.
I'm sure that all you got to do is just get up there and say
that, you know, immigrants commit less crime per capita and everyone's
going to be like, "Wait, I didn't know that. You know what? Don't
think we need a border." You know, like test this theory, you
know, like there's nothing stopping him from testing this theory.
There's literally nothing stopping him. He has significant resources.
He has significant Oh, I think it's absolutely Hold on. If socialized
housing were like more widespread like it was in the communist
block, I don't think that people talk about socialized housing
as being like bad or awful or whatever, I don't think it's necessarily
awful. I don't I think it can work. I think you just need to
have certain values, yeah, that aren't there in America. Like
if you built socialized housing in Norway, I think it would do
fine. Unironically, I think it could be totally fine.
In America? Nah. typically networked
with enough people that would put up money for him frankly to
do something like this, to make a whole production of Have people
follow him around with a camera crew and uh Of course these days
Why is Hasan talking about these things and saying other people
should do them when he doesn't do them himself?
Uh the same reason everybody in the internet talks about why
people should do things, probably. These are a little bit more
dangerous, so I obviously wouldn't want anything like that to
happen to them, but you can go out there and you can try to make
these pitches to people and you don't need to be a politician
and and that's the you know activist groups. They're not politicians.
They're they're they're just out there trying to engage in the
communities that they operate in and trying to like build political
power in the in a very grassroots kind of way. He can go do that.
He can go pitch like no borders to uh deep red districts and
just all you got to do is just show them the crime statistics
and they'll they'll come around, you know. He didn't piss the
office off so I mean I yeah, I disagree with Bernie Sanders'
is is message around that because obviously yes, nation states
have well-defined borders and boundaries. But my point about
it is he he can say that Or the audience with the [__]
without with confidence because everyone knows what Bernie Sanders
stands for. Yes. And so when he is asked about trans issues,
when he is asked
issues in which Democrats are not at Didn't Bernie say something
about trans issues?
About the like the the trans people in sports. Has Bernie Sanders
commented on
Uh the thing Hutch never seems to understand is when you have
like a positive message that is inspiring, you can have other
issues where people will vote against maybe what they even care
about because you're just that good, right? Unfortunately, Trump
has become almost somebody who could be considered just that
good on immigration, maybe a couple other issues where he can
do other [__] that's like pretty insane and it it
still carries water, right? It still still holds its own. Like
people will still believe in him somehow even when he lies.
You got to have a message, right? The and unfortunately for Hutch
as well, the message of like America's and you're getting [__]
over seems to be the strongest messaging that goes right now.
Trans people in sports. Or does he always do the like it's just
a distraction thing? I thought he I thought even he was like
I understand why people have concerns. I thought I thought I
he I thought it though. 55 45 but it's 30 70. Whatever it may
be, he can either say, you know what? I don't care about that.
I'm not talking about that. Or he can answer in a way that maybe
rile some of the base, but you trust him. And that to me is the
Uh he's losing some of his luster here, Tyzka, but I'm talking
about him getting
I'm sorry. I'm going to say that maybe the least honest, least
principled candidate ever being elected twice as president in
eight years or whatever, that's going to be proof that he's very
good at messaging. He's got something that he is accomplishing
very
And I I understand that most people some people won't like that
argument. Seems pretty obvious to me. The connection between
honestly the kind of like what seems a bit frivolous like are
we having fun and the actual hard work of politics. Like Zoran,
you said was moderating in the last few weeks of the campaign.
I was glad to see that. Tim and I are both
The malice came out against him and I was like, okay, we're in
business now, >> I mean he was the reason why Zoran was
moderating on I don't know what he was moderating on. What did
hold on. What did what did Tim just say when who came out against
him?
The malice came out against him and I was like, okay, we're in
business When the malice came out against him, I see. now, Z.
I mean he was the reason why Zoran was moderating on I don't
know what he was moderating I feel like I feel like Tim said
that specifically as a shot at Hassan when the malice came I
feel like he was like looking directly at Hassan when he said
that. >> rating on. I guess like maybe he was talking about
like the policing stuff even though it was Now that the election
is over, we can be honest about it. That Zoran Momdani did this
brilliant thing that got liberals to to basically come to terms
with a lot of things that liberal media had considered radical,
right? Cuz he had a way with he he had a he had a really good
way of communicating these >> Can you generously call that
he did a good job of listening, seeming curious and being persuasive
to bring more people into his Sure. Yes. But but one of the things
that he did but he was still uncompromising. Good. I feel so
bad for Hassan when he goes on things cuz basically every single
time he goes on anything, does any sort of collaboration,
he gets reminded,
hey man, you're like the least concise speaker, okay? Hassan
and Tyzka share a gene. I'll be real with you guys. I see it.
I can see it very clearly. They share a gene. All right, it's
the yapper
Like you could just make this point really easily, but you're
going to yap about a bunch of [__] nobody cares about.
Hey, how about you stop yapping?
Could you could you just Just please in in any possible way could
you be a little more concise? Please.
And Hassan gets hit with it all the time. Could you say just
these three words? Yeah, I guess so, but I need to yap a lot
more. Defund the police always was about making sure that the
headcount either remains stable, but then we actually turned
around and restructured some The headcount remains stable. What
does that even mean? Like don't hire more police? That is wildly
unpopular. First of all, there was no real agreement on defund
the what defund the police
like even meant. For people like Cinema marks is
Wait, there's no Is he saying the position of don't change anything
about police right now? Like police seem to be doing fine. Like
I don't I don't want to defund the police. I want to leave the
police as they are. That's wildly unpopular. Leave the police
as they are is wildly unpopular.
That seems kind of weird. I have no idea what you're talking
about, Tyzka, but I can almost guarantee you're a complete [__]
head.
I have no I literally have no idea what you're talking about.
You completely got humiliated in this spoliation argument
at every turn.
But surely something that got posted today saved it. It it made
it so you aren't really
There's there was hypothetical information that could have existed
that apparently exists now that has shown you're not a real
incredible. I'm when we had that conversation, it was about like
police and prison abolition. I mean they were very marginalized.
That was a very fringe part of the left, but there were I I would
love to hear that. Listen, I want you to go over to the Discord,
Tyzka, and put whatever that evidence is, okay? Would would love
to see it. It would be >> There were a lot of people calling
for that in 2020 online. There were a lot of voices. Per capita,
probably not that much. And
like the more sanitized kind of like defund the police or like
the what what people what it seemed like the serious people were
pushing for
redirecting some of the funds that was supposed to go to police
precincts to social programs, to send in social workers into
like non-violent
situations. And there have been various cities across the country
that have done this kind of thing and it was very successful.
But people were so freaked out by the by the phrase defund the
police that it made actually doing
Oh, wait.
Wait, what? Tyzka, go ahead, post the evidence you're talking
about, yeah. I Just to be clear, Tyzka, I am going to have to
point out if you're wrong on this, all right, I haven't looked
into any of the evidence from today, but you've just said that
apparently the spoliation allegations totally retracted. I would
love to see
if that's true and if it's not true, come on and say I'm a complete
and I'm sorry for interrupting your stream, okay? But I will
look into this. If we if you go send me the paragraphs you want
to send me, I will look into it. We'll come to a determination
as a group and then if you are wrong, you have to come on and
say you're a complete
doing those reforms more difficult because it was just a horrible
slogan. You know, he claims to be like, you know, I keep telling
>> only way do this thing and you know, maybe they would
attract
loyal audience like I can find in my Twitch chat. All all Democratic
Party need to do is just like I'm just I keep telling them they
got to do this thing and you know, like make sure we don't hire
any more cops. It's like
Like 95% of the country opposes this and it's actually even more
true when you go into black communities. Oh, I didn't If you
go into black I didn't say Tyzka was going to come on stream
and talk about anything, Chris. I said he's going to come on
and admit that he's a That's all. communities. Did you guys know
that they're even more opposed to defunding the police than white
communities? By like double digits. Overwhelming margins like
85 to 95%.
Everybody knows that. Everybody knows that black people actually
do want police because they're the people who experience like
rampant crime in their communities. Everybody knows that. Uh
like voters in black communities do not want to reduce the amount
of policing that is in their neighborhoods. Does Badani with
$10 to someone who lives in NYC NYPD seeing a reduction in cops
would be a huge blow to Zora I mean I have to I have to point
out, okay, just
as a funny meme that when I asked Tyzka to show me the evidence
of this, he goes, wait, where do I find the court documents?
So I I'll say we're not off to a great start, all right? When
it starts with wait, where do I find the court documents again?
Not a good start for him. Doesn't mean he's wrong necessarily,
but I would assume that if you wanted to make that claim, you
probably just want to have looked at that stuff
Bronz admin Believe it or not, NYC residents generally like cops.
It's why Eric Adams won in 2021.
If he actually does do that, if he actually does with the NYPD,
that is not going to be good for him politically. And if he's
smart, he won't do that and if he doesn't do that, he's going
to piss off his like online base of support.
I am so Hold on.
Uh I just I
A lot of people just don't care about looking like total [__]
heads. He said, let me find them, not where to find them. And
then he went to the Discords and said, hey, where do I find them?
Where do I find them? That's literally what he asked. Where do
I find them? Where do I find them? Where do I find them?
That's That's what he asked. So curious how this guy's going
to govern. His first day in office, I will be watching that very
closely to see where he's going. Oh my god, we just proposed
a lot. Uh okay. Oh, hold on. Momdani NYPD.
I remember reading when he was campaigning that he he not going
to he was not By >> By the way, I'm not gloating, Tysca.
I'm just going to what I'm doing here, okay? Just the the lesson
you should take away from this is that for some reason your capacity
to be contrarian knows no bounds. So, you wanted to come in and
be contrarian in the chat without really knowing, and I know
you don't really know or you'd be able to to cite this thing
correctly. Saiber disagrees with you. Maybe Saiber is wrong.
I don't have a position. I just I know that you try to get contrarian
for no reason. You told me I was wrong. So, I said, "Prove it."
That's it.
running on defund the police, right? Uh all eyes will be on how
he tried Oh, the lesson is that basically if you are just being
contrarian
then then you better have your arguments down, okay? Good luck.
I'll be fighting in a moment. All right. tries to make Sorry,
I should I should get back to Hutch. good on many of his policy
Although, I was also going to cover some of the Destiny stuff
from
I got told that Desti- Did Destiny do a spreadsheet of like which
orbiters he would bring back if he wins the court
Is that real?
But I heard that was happening, and I was like, "No shot." I
don't believe
But maybe it did happen. See proposals including potentially
spending $1 billion on a Department of Community Safety, which
he says would give civilians some of the responsibilities currently
handled by police officers. The centerpiece of the projected
winner's public safety plan relies on mental health workers responding
before the NYPD to certain situations. So, yeah, this is like
this was the the this was the what I thought defund the police
was. Relies on mental health workers responding before the NYPD
to certain situations involving emotionally disturbed disturbed
individuals.
Like some homeless people on the subways Cringle Kanesh, I I
argued that Fuentes didn't agree to a debate. So, to back down
from a debate you'd have to agree to a debate. I just said he
I don't believe he agreed to a
That's all. But it's fine. Go go off, king. >> Donny said
he believes the current size of the NY >> Go off, buddy.
>> PD is appropriate and has not called for increasing
the number of officers. However, he said he would instead change
existing officers' responsibilities freeing up more of them to
do what they signed up for and are trained for, such as respond
to shootings, murders, and other serious crimes. Our vision for
a Department of Community Safety, the DCS
is what we would have teams of dedicated mental health outreach
workers that we deployed to the hundred subway stations with
the highest levels of mental health crises to respond to those
incidents and to get those New Yorkers out of the subway system
and to the services they actually need. >> In addition
to mental health res- Hutch is going over social workers, okay?
Rapid response social workers. I It's a very silly policy. I
would agree it's a silly policy. There's some idea of like, "Hey,
I'm calling the cops because I need like the cops to do
I think maybe for like mental health crises this is a good idea,
possibly. But then again, in in some mental health like areas
I think that having a cop there can be helpful cuz sometimes
people can become violent. So, I That it's like 50/50. I I want
to see how that plays out. I don't know about like creating a
whole new department. That seems to be a novel approach. Programs
such or similar Tysca, nobody asked what Destiny believes. I
get that you maybe put this in the chat GPT or some [__]
Okay. We We don't need your just You said that apparently the
expert witness took back the allegations of spoliation, and that
made you win the argument you had with me. So, I just wanted
your evidence of
I know that's confusing, but I I know that's confusing.
I'm not mad at you. I know it's confusing for you. I'm sorry.
or to to this kind of thinking have been done and have been successful
in the past, and so But then we actually turned around and restructured
some Defund the police is very Now now who's doing Now you're
the PR guy. That's the most politically you've sounded. But but
the thing is the thing is it has a bad rap. No matter what you
say or do, uh Democrats immediately attacked it. They said this
is a danger, and it's partially because Americans really love
police. It's unfortunate. I don't know how because they don't
don't do their [__] jobs ever, but Bro, there like
I like I
I understand a lot of the anger that gets directed at police,
specifically in the context of when there are protest movements.
That kind of conflict
Um hold on. Uh I don't want to I want to finish this video, okay?
Then we can we can discuss the case. If we're going to do that,
we'll discuss the case after. between local police and usually
younger protest movements, typically when they become violent,
produce some really ugly ugly awful images and videos of police
brutality. It's very not that rare in a country this big with
so many protest movements that pop up sometimes
to find, you know, sometimes you log on to Twitter and you're
like looking at five different videos of cops that are just using
just way too much force. And you know, when you look at ICE officers
these days, they are
doing it Well, like I don't know what their training is like
over there. I don't know how they're vetting ICE candidates,
but there are a lot apparently per capita. There is no I'm seeing
way more examples of that kind of like amateur hour violent [__]
like pulling out your pistol and aiming it at someone cuz they're
recording you or what- Like that [__] is crazy right
now with ICE. But 99.9999%
of police officers' job in a given year has nothing to do with
protests. They're responding to domestic violence calls. They're
often times interacting with people who are having the worst
the of their lives, interacting with their communities, you know?
Like my sister was has been a cop for a long time.
I know what kind of person she is. I've known her my whole life.
That is someone that deeply cares about the community that she
serves, that goes out of her way to actually serve that community.
I like I know her character very very well. I've no doubt that
she is a huge asset to her community. And there's just Like this
is the real story of police officers. I understand this is not
like the most popular take online. And
also spent a lot of time around cops growing up. I've spent a
lot of time around cops like at family functions.
And there's a lot of stuff about police culture that, you know,
I frankly don't like. I'm I'm not going to get into particulars
cuz it's like private stuff, but there's stuff that makes me
uncomfortable for sure. And that, you know, I don't understand
at all. But this idea that cops are not out there like helping
people every day. Like I think if you want to like I think I
think like the really online take is like people think that cops
are just out there brutalizing Okay, hold on. Let's just do We'll
do a quick aside. Oh, we'll do a quick aside for this Tysca thing.
So, my claim was I believe that in
I feel like delete When you're the perpetrator of a crime deleting
the impartial evidence
could be akin to spoliation, and that a third party is the person
is the group that would that should handle that. So, you should
go to your lawyers and you say, "Hey, I need a service or I need
you to handle removing this evidence, the spoliation stuff, right?
I need I So, so as to not spoil it. So, as to not delete it or
modify, okay?"
That was the point. We can fight over this later. Oh, you want
to fight over this? I don't necessarily want to fight over this
on stream.
I I honestly don't necessarily want to fight over this over stream.
I was just going to go over and say, "But that's my position."
So, I don't understand where this testimony undoes my position,
but I'm excited cuz Tysca said it did. I think people like 99%
of the time or whatever or maybe you could say all the
>> And I think the reality is is like the vast vast vast
vast vast majority of stuff that cops do are very real important
services for the communities that they serve in. There are a
lot of cops out there right now that are just like helping people.
Yeah, there's my Norman Rockwell brave hot take. You know, cops
are pretty good generally, I'm going to say. And I think they
do really important work. And I think most communities feel safer
with more cops in their communities. So, what W cops.
W cops. >> does that tell you about the work that they're
doing? If it was true that cops were just out here spending most
of their time like Uh does Hutch realize that like the cop issue
Is that not To me it feels kind of like a little bit
a little bit like one of those wedge things where I don't know
how many people are talking about the cops being bad anymore.
Are people doing that broadly? Sargon talked about how shitty
the cops were. I I know he went there. I can't even remember
what the original topic was that got him here.
Was Sargon talking about like defunding the police? They talked
about Zohran Mamdani. Zohran Mamdani said, "Oh, it was that Zohran
Mamdani said he wouldn't [__] with the NYPD." That's
what it was, right? Zohran Mamdani ran on, "I'm not going to
touch the NYPD. They're doing just fine." like brutalizing people,
brutalizing their own communities. Why do the overwhelming majority
of people want more cops in their communities?
How do you explain that? And we would have to dive into stuff
like I am very much aware of the statistical
evidence
of systemic racism. This is something that we don't talk about
as much these days, but I believe that systemic racism is a real
thing. And I think we have the numbers that can just plainly
demonstrate that there's a disparity of treatment. We do need
a police culture in the United States that is more that emphasizes
transparency a lot more. And you know, the good news with Biden
was like because of his administration he did something with
police cameras. Was it all police cameras? He did something with
police cameras. And now like basically every cop wears a police
camera. And then and then Biden also took steps to like beef
up accountability for police officers. Like his Department of
Justice, I think, were pretty aggressively
going out there across the country and looking into claims of
excessive violence and or
Tycho, you you literally started arguing with me. You were you
were arguing with me at first.
corruption problems within certain cities or whatever. But he
did do a lot of like meaningful stuff. But at the same time he
also funded the [__] out of police. He sent hundreds
of millions of into the country to flow into police departments.
I might have even been billions, I don't even remember. But I
just feel like this is like you talk about out of touch, bro.
He's talking about the He's giving advice to the Democratic Party
for how to get back in touch with voters and he's saying like
I don't know why people want more police. It's like
Okay. And I would really attacked it. They said this is a danger
and it's partially because Americans really love police. It's
unfortunate. I don't know how because they don't do their jobs
ever, but and I wish they would cuz I I'm not like I'm not saying
we I really wish like feel like that's going to be in a campaign
ad at some point. >> We want to live in a world where police
never do their jobs ever. I want to be able to call the police.
I just don't want them to think I'm a suspect when they show
up. >> Exactly. Exactly.
We want Look at Oh my god, Tim is just like oh god.
Hold on. How can I be wrong if I didn't Okay. Never mind. Uh
Tycho, just go do whatever you're going to do. I'm going to watch
this Hutch thing, okay? Stop bringing it up in chat right now.
Like what is happening?
Like part of him is dying inside.
We want a presence of law and order and unfortunately in many
communities police's presence is lawlessness and disorder. Now
having said that, having said that I I just It's like again,
if this narrative is true, you would not see this many Americans
wanting more police in their neighborhoods. Like what he's saying
I guess like if you take it at face value, there's like a lot
of people He's essentially saying there's like a lot of cops
that are doing bad things. I mean that's true, but like are you
saying most cops are just out there like just terrorizing their
neighborhoods? If if that was true, how do you explain those
numbers? It just That doesn't make any sense. Um I think it's
probably those same neighborhoods being like terrorized way more
by the actual criminals in them. And that if they have to choose
between one or the other, they're going to choose the like least
harmful party. I >> He wanted to to not reduce the headcount
necessarily, but at least like bring in social workers to take
away some of the bandwidth, some of the workload from the police.
And that was a That was a message that that resonated with even
Tim Miller, it seems. >> want to but I He liked it. >> I
but I >> You want to defund the police now.
I want to
Can I just just really quick cuz I think like like Simone, I'm
like you're talking you're talking to him. I'm like yeah, yeah,
yeah. Then he says something like dude, bro.
Here here's so but here's the here's I think what Zoran did well
that kind of combines part of what you're talking about with
what what maybe I think what I think I'm happy he didn't take
your advice on part of part of his campaign. But what he did
well to the Are we having fun fun yet? Zoran was happy. He's
having a good time. He is he is a fun hang here on my my part.
We had a great time. He had he had he had a couple specific things.
Yeah, dude, he cooked him on globalize the intifada. I did Well,
that wasn't his best answer. That wasn't his best answer. But
but we but he we were vibing though and the people that listened
to the pod liked it. He had four issues like you mentioned. Like
it was it's kind of hard to know what Kamala's issues were. I
think if we had if you quizzed all of us on here, everybody would
say different things. Everybody knew what Zoran's issues were.
That that was >> I would get an A plus. I'll tell you what
she was about. She ran on affordability just to be clear. It
was a
You wanted to incentivize
two to three million new home development with a series of incentives
that I don't know the particulars of. It was a government subsidy
for first-time home buyers. I think it was $25,000
assistance to help first-time home buyers. There are I think
roughly a million new home buyers each year. So, you know, not
nothing, but pretty targeted. Price gouging thing, anti-price
gouging, the
border bill, but >> Was he really People have been saying
this. Was he really the political strategist for Jeb? That seems
pretty crazy to me.
That's like maybe the worst or a political strategist. Dude,
he couldn't have been high up in that campaign cuz that's like
the worst credentials ever. I ran I ran the Jeb Bush 2016 campaign.
There literally there literally are no worse credentials than
that. That may be the worst political campaign ever run. Although
it would speak to his ability to entertain people if he has those
credentials and he still gets viewership. All right. It might
be evidence that this guy is like a really compelling speaker.
This guy, Tim Miller, was apparently
Tim Miller.
We got a WikiP political strategist.
Tim Miller is an American political commentator, writer, and
former political consultant.
McCain Bush campaigns. He was hired in 2015 by former Florida
Governor Jeb Bush as a senior advisor to Bush's presidential
exploratory campaign Right to Rise political action committee
and went on to act as the communication director for Bush's presidential
campaign.
Miller followed Trump around the spin room Oh, sorry. Following
a 2016 South South Carolina Republican primary debate, Miller
followed Trump around the spin room heckling him until Miller
was hip-checked
by Trump campaign strategist Corey Lewandowski. Dude, Corey Lewandowski
just beat up everybody. You want to criticize Donald Trump? Yeah,
we'll criticize this fist, bro. Ah. Amazing stuff. Also like
a pathway to citizenship and like uh humane immigration reform.
Those were kind of like the big three things I think. Now that
I think about it. I mean listen, again, I do think her her campaign
was too targeted, kind of too specific, too kind of like focus
tested. It was too kind of was difficult to like you got to like
tighten it up, you know, like I want to give you guys money to
buy homes, you know? You should say it like that instead of we're
going to do $25,000 grant for people that make under this income
under this income, you know, and in between this bracket or whatever.
Like don't get so technocratic and [__] complicated
with it. 25K to new home buyers doesn't fix the housing market.
Well, it was a I dude, I swear to god I'm like super ADHD right
now. So I apologize to everybody watching, okay? But this is
a short that just popped up for me on YouTube and I don't know
what it is. This is This is the short that popped up. Candace
is literally doing the face.
She's She's literally doing the face. What do you think this
is? She won. What did she win? I won. I won. I won. I didn't
expect it. I played it cool, but it's recently now been announced
that it is me. I am the anti-Semite of the year. Some people
Uh she did kind of win though. God damn. two-pronged approach.
It was like abundance built by trying to trying to do a public-private
partnership with developers to build two to three million new
homes, I think it was, but that number needed to be much higher,
like 20 million. You know, it's not enough to do two million,
like 20 million. Um At the more than that at the federal level.
It should have been should have been bigger. Uh so like she wanted
to boost the housing supply, but then also provide direct assistance
to first-time home buyers. But no, it doesn't fix the problem.
Isn't subsidizing demand just going to lead to higher prices?
It would in a vacuum, but if you're stimulating development and
increasing the inventory, then you can you can kind of offset,
right? As with any subsidy,
You You just somebody asked about one policy. Hey, if you're
stimulating demand, doesn't that increase price? The answer is
yes. Just say yes.
She decided she wanted to stimulate both demand and supply at
the same time. And yes, that could in technically it could technically
increase prices, especially when you consider the fact that
a lot of the houses that are going to get built
are probably not being built yet. It's going to take a while
for them to come out of the market. So if you start stimulating
demand before stimulating
before you start stimulating supply, then yeah, you're going
to have higher prices. You don't want the subsidy to be so big
that you're like flooding the market and driving prices up, right?
>> He's good. He's good on that. He could go on a pod with
me or with somebody else. He could have gone on Rogan for 3 hours
and hung out and had a good time. So he could communicate. He's
happy. He had a He had a three issues. But three or four issues.
But he also just did like making the practical decision to say
he was going to keep the police chief rather than doubling down
on the tweets that he sent in 2019 was smart practical politics.
Like you can you can have clear left-wing policy issues that
people understand. You can be positive and optimistic and you
can also be practical. He did all of that like quite well, actually.
>> I'll give you I I agree with that. I think his messaging
was good on that and that's precisely what I was talking about.
Like for example, okay, especially not in like the the broader
population's understanding of this issue, but like in mainstream
media and in American politics, there's a major
uh division between how the population is receiving what Israel
is doing and and how our politicians are responding to it, right?
And and how the media even responds to it. Anti-Zionism is like
a scary term or a scary word for a lot of media professionals
in a way that like, you know, being anti-Israel is not necessarily
scary at all for the average person. As a matter of fact, they
are very anti-Israel now and there's polling to reflect on that
reality. Now what Zoran did so perfectly
to to communicate his position in a way that liberals understand
it. He turned around and said, "Yeah, Israel has a right to exist
as a nation-state that has equal rights and representation for
all people." That is identifying that Israel is a is is has a
ethno-state project, right? That is identifying that Israel has
a exterminationist policy on the Palestinians.
And and I don't think that part. I think you could maybe argue
it it addresses the apartheid thing. I don't think it says that
they're committing a genocide.
It's incredibly repressive policies on policies You are not You
are
out of your mind if you think that Zoran Mundani is going to
change people's opinion to Uh Tyskyy, you're just you're Everybody
can see where it's going, right? This is Trust me, it's
Being anti-Israel is not a big deal for people anymore. It's
not. It's straight up not, and you can say that it's like an
issue that's electorally unpopular. I don't think it is. I totally
disagree. And you can say it's only like young people. I think
that's only where That's the only place the major shifts are
happening, where it's like majority people are against it. But
it used to be that like everybody supported Israel. It's way,
way, way different now.
to be like a one-state solution. That's what Hassan's talking
about here.
By the way, you got to read between the lines a little bit here,
but this is This is him like pushing a one-state solution. And
I don't know if he is suggesting that Zoran Mumdani is like convincing
a bunch of New Yorkers to push for a one-state solution, but
that is going to be a fringe opinion, even in New York City,
I think. Hold on. Hold on. It's He's pushing for what he's pushing
for.
Just listen to what he's saying. He's just pushing for what he's
pushing for,
He's saying everybody should have the same rights in the state
of Israel.
What part of that do you disagree with,
Just say the part you disagree with. It's pretty simple to understand,
okay? I think Hassan does want a single-state solution, single-state
democracy.
But realistically, a two-state solution is the same thing. That's
exactly what he said, right?
One One nation, one vote, or one nation, one people, one vote
for per person or
So you can you can cut those places out and let them be another
country on their own, or
you could have one country and everybody gets a vote. But if
you're going to maintain dominion over these countries,
then you need to give them votes.
One state is crazy. One state is crazy now. It's not a crazy
It's literally the foundational
The The one state, one vote thing is foundational to all Western
liberal democracies, right? Everybody votes. Everybody gets a
vote.
If you want no representation No taxation without representation.
No getting held in like a
in a cow pen, pig pen
without representation.
All right?
So yes, Hassan Hassan's absolutely a one-stater, but he's not
saying Mumdani's a one-stater. He's saying this is what I think
Mumdani's communicating
Qatar, too? Does Qatar have a right to exist only if everybody
has equal rights for all religions? Is that true for Qatar? I
No, but Qatar's not a democracy.
And the predi- the the pretense under which the United States
supports Israel, the biggest one for the longest time has been
it is a beacon of democracy and Western values in a sea of barbarity.
If you want to drop that talking point, say Israel are barbarians,
Israelis are barbarians, go That's fine. Israel are like totally
savage barbarians who don't follow our customs at all. We don't
support them. Cool. Or we support them for the resources they
provide. Cool. Those are all fine. Do those. I don't Or just
Israel. No, I don't care. I mean, yeah, okay. No nation has a
right to exist, including Qatar. Like I don't know why you're
bringing up Qatar like as though I'm going to be like, "Oh my
god, Qatar." Well, because there are a lot of countries in the
Middle East that you could call ethno-state adjacent.
And yet Israel is the only country that is talked about when
we talk about like
That's the point that he's making here. Qatar, like they pay
me so much I'm just I'm just saying I don't know why that's the
only country that doesn't have a right to exist unless they give
equal rights for everybody. Well, because it's an ethno-state.
So are all the all of the countries in that region are >> you
can Qatar's an ethno-state, Iran's an ethno-state, Jordan's an
ethno-state, Saudi's an ethno-state. He's never
this kind of You never see this kind of pushback cuz it's just
him on his stream or if he invites somebody to come on his stream.
Okay, hold on. Norway's an ethno-state, too. It's about what
you're doing to accomplish that ethno-state,
That's obviously That's obviously the question here. What are
you doing to make sure that ethno-state survives? Do you have
it written to your laws? Is there a law that says Saudi Arabia
or any of those other countries have to be ethno-states? Now
they're autocracies, they don't have to have laws that say that,
but in any case, Norway's Japan's an ethno-state. It depends
on how you accomplish it. If you're accomplishing it through
like ethnic cleansing and genocide, it's really bad. Obviously.
That's obvious. That's clear,
If you're going to ethnically cleanse to to achieve an ethno-state,
that's bad.
That's not hard to understand.
Tim is usually a friend. Like you just never see this kind of
pushback ever cuz he's He stopped doing debates, you know? So
I don't think any country has a right to exist unless they give
equal rights for everybody. Well, because it's an ethno-state.
So are all the all of the countries in that region are ethno-states.
Qatar's an ethno- Wait, hold on. I
I can see
I I I see I can I can see everything,
Huh. He's not going to Did he say Hold on. Maybe maybe I don't
see.
I just want to see if he says, "Yeah, obviously Israel's an ethno-state,
but where does he go Does he without saying it at all does he
just go, 'Well, all the countries in that region are
Hassan should have just gone, "So you agree Israel's an ethno-state
then." That's all he had to do, right? You agree Israel's an
ethno-state then,
I guarantee you Tim would have short-circuited. He could have
cut the Zogbot circuit right there. He could have shorted it,
and Hassan failed. He had this chance He had He had the chance,
and he failed. everybody Well, because it's an ethno-state. So
are all the all of the countries in that region are ethno-states.
Qatar's an So you agree that Israel's an ethno-state then. That's
all you got to You agree. ethno-state Do you people deny that
it's an ethno-state? Yes. Yep, they'll deny it's an ethno-state.
Iran's an ethno-state, Jordan's an ethno-state, Saudi's an ethno-state.
So I'm okay with criticizing Israel. I'm just saying let's Israel
is the least clear example of an ethno-state of any of its neighbors.
Okay, can you show me the ethnic cleansing that Jordan did?
You show me the ethnic cleansing that Jordan did to achieve
um an ethnic majority, like post-United Nations
Tyskyy, you got it. I believe in you, buddy. I believe in you.
Israel isn't ethnically cleansing Israel.
I I could have sworn
I could have sworn they actually literally ethnically cleansed
Israel. What is the Nakba? Sorry, what What was the Nakba?
Is that not literally an ethnic
I think that's like expected to That's That's considered an ethnic
cleansing by
I didn't ask for Turkey, Tyskyy. You Tyskyy, reevaluate your
claim, you [__] I'm going to have to time you out
cuz you actually are too stupid to argue with. But you have it
written out here. Israel is the least clear example of an ethno-state
of any of its neighbors. I picked a neighbor, you [__]
I said Jordan. Don't start talking about Turkey, idiot. Talk
about Jordan. I just gave you a literal land neighbor, okay?
A land border neighbor. Talk about Jordan. Explain to me how
Jordan is a more clear example of an ethno-state than Israel.
Jesus Christ. I So you're okay So you're okay with all of these
other countries being ethno-states then, and you're not just
using that as a deflective mechanism to move the attention >> if
you're going to push for like, you >> This is why I call
Tyskyy stupid. He just He just made up a different thing equal
rights and democracy or whatever.
Israel is, you know,
There's millions of people that live there, but the bro, in in
terms of like The population of Israel as a percentage of the
entire Middle East, what even is that? I don't even know. What
is the
of the entire Okay, show me the ethnic cleansing that took place
to to forcibly
keep the ethnic majority in place, Tyskyy. That's what I'm asking
you to do. higher Middle East. Damn. Okay, 500 million. And then
Israel's population is what, like 11 million people? Is every
Also, Tyskyy, is every country in Africa an ethno-state?
I assume an ethno-state, by the way, has to have some sort of
idea of how it maintains an ethnic majority, right?
That that's foundational to the country. That that is important
to the country in some way. Is that right? 9.4 million. 9.4 divided
by 501 million. 9.4 divided by 501. That is Israel is one The
entire population of Israel, and that's not including Gaza. And
if you include Gaza and West Bank, it's What is it? 3 million
more? 4 million more? It's like 1 to 2% of the entire Middle
East. There's a lot of people in the Middle East. So if we're
going to have a conversation about ethno-states, it's kind of
absurd to to focus on Israel. It's like the only topic of It's
They're what? Israel's actively
ethnically cleansing to claim more territory in their area
while claiming all of the benefits of a liberal democracy. Free
trade with all of these places. They're not sanctioned They Before
the Israel-Gaza war, they weren't sanctioned massively.
They're double-dipping.
Pick a system that you agree with. Stop double-dipping, bro.
Don't be Don't say you're a Western democracy, and then also
have these people penned up for
Not cool. Are they the smallest country in the Middle East in
terms of population? away from Israel, a country that literally
receives more aid and more political support than from the United
States of America than anyone else. As a matter of fact, a lot
of people actually get mad about Qatar because now the Gulf leaders
have realized, "Oh, if we give this guy jets, He's not really
like engaging in what Tim said by I mean, this is He's accusing
Tim of deflecting, and he's now he's deflecting and giving a
sermon.
He's going to defend us, too. We're oil barons. It's awesome.
And And that And that's the reason why I almost feel like people
who defend Israel are jealous that like now other Gulf nations
are trying to do like Israel-style things over there.
Is she saying that Hutch didn't like that? Hold on. People who
defend Israel are jealous that like now other Gulf nations are
trying to do like Israel-style things over there.
IS SHE saying that Middle Eastern countries didn't used to be
ethno-states and now they're all doing like ethno-state stuff
because Israel came into existence? What is he saying? I don't
even understand what he's saying right there. PLEASE, BRING US
BACK. >> SORRY. ANYWAY,
I WOULD SAY I WOULD SAY THIS. LOOK, I DON'T I don't know I have
I have disagreements with you on this, as you
I will say that Zoran had a challenge, right? And part of his
challenge was >> Uh dude, this guy's like I do not Can
you stop talking about Israel? Stop talking about Israel. a lot
of New
that are deeply worried about some of his past comments and which
he has and he spent a lot of time trying to reassure those people.
I think because he recognized that there was a liability
in some of the ways in which his previous statements and some
of his positions were seen by a lot of New Yorkers, which is
where more Jews on Earth live than in any other place than in
Israel. I think it would So that So like and he sought to address
it. Now, without This is like such an important part and I I
think this conversation is frustrating because it feels like
they're getting sidetracked so easily.
But this is a really important part. How could you How could
you resist the idea that a candidate like let's just say Spanberger
in Virginia would moderate on a number of issues. Like he was
like very dis- Uh again, isn't Jordan preventing Palestinians
from being citizens to maintain their ethnic superiority?
Jordanians are like essentially the same ethnic group. Like being
across the Jordan River, you're not a different ethnic group.
I I don't believe there's a a significant not or a significant
significant divergence in the ethnic group between those two
countries
between the Palestinian Arabs and the Jordanian Arabs.
They don't give Palestinians citizenship because they don't want
the Palestine issue to be solved, right?
They don't want that to be solved. They generally don't give
them citizenship because if they get citizenship in Jordan, they
would no longer be
dismissive of the the post >> Also, giving them citizenship
in Jordan
like allows for um Oh, how would you call it? Giving them citizenship
in Jordan basically invites a ton of issues with the PLO. Was
around the time there was major groups of Palestinian Arabs there,
like people who came who were refugees. So giving that refugee
group citizenship, that's like you're just inviting PLO issues.
2024 election analysis from Deciding to Win. So people are saying
that Palestinian Arabs are actually the majority of Jordan. in
which basically said that you know, on a number of issues there
needs to be some moderation or whatever, but you know, the way
that he described it was like, "Oh, big surprise. They want everybody
to moderate like they've been doing for the last two decades
or whatever," he
And this is a really important counterpoint because even in New
York City, even with an a self-described Democratic Socialist
like Mondani running for the mayor's office in New York City,
even he moderated. He didn't remain like ideologically pure.
Like even he moderated. And Hassan said he understood why he
did that. Thought it was smart. If you understand why a far-left
candidate running in a D plus 30
D plus 30 city, if you're saying it's smart for them to moderate
in that city, well, you're going to have a much more conservative
electorate in a compared to the entire state of like Virginia.
And so that candidate you should reasonably expect that that
candidate is going to be probably significantly more moderate
than than Mondani. And this isn't a bad thing. This is just like
smart strategy. Just smart politics. That's like the overall
point of like what this conversation is about. And it just keeps
getting sidetracked. Like how That's not what the Wait, what?
That's not what I mean that's might be what you want to make
the conversation
But that that's not necessarily what the conversation has to
be about, right?
response to Zoran Mondani.
So it doesn't have to be about that or that's one side of it.
It doesn't only have to be about that. You can talk about other
issues. The whole The whole concept of this discussion is why
do people dislike Democrats?
Right? So hey, if you if you constantly should talk if you refuse
to endorse my candidate who I believe in, then yeah, I'm going
to be disenchanted with the Democratic Party is the point is
like the the broad talking point from Hassan's side. How the
[__] do we get on Israel? What the Without getting
into the details of where we >> he had to do that cuz he's
Muslim. I'mma be honest, I think it was racism. Hold hold hold
on. the liability
in some of the ways in which his previous statements and some
of his positions were seen by a lot of New Yorkers, which is
where This is about So he Mondani disavowed globalize the intifada.
I think he might have even apologized, said that that phrase
caused a lot of pain
and I think that's what they're talking about here. more Jews
on Earth live than in any other place.
Uh it's just it's very funny, Tequila
I understand there's a big issue during the election.
I think Am I the only person who sits here and I'm like, "Actually
it was brilliant of him to just like say, yeah, I care about
New Yorkers. I don't care about Israel. I care about New Yorkers."
I think there's a lot of people who who want to read a lot of
ideas into what Mondani was saying about Israel. It seemed like
Mondani to me was like, "I don't want to talk about
I stop talking about Israel. Stop talking about it. Nobody cares.
Right? Nobody cares about Israel. I care about citizens in New
York, but I don't give a [__] about Israel because
Israel is not New York City.
than in Israel. I think it would So that So like and he sought
to address it. Now, without getting into the details of where
we >> he had to do that cuz he's Muslim. I'mma be honest,
I think it was racism, straight up. He had never said a single
thing that was even remotely anti-Semitic and yet the media constantly
kept needling him on that.
I don't agree with that and I and I don't agree with that because
honestly impossible to know because it's over determined, right?
Do I think there's anti- that there is Islamophobia in the reaction
to Zoran? Of course there is. Do I think there's genuine concerns
about some of the things he said? Of course there is. You can't
tease me what Hold on. You can't tease it out. What was what
was concern? Well, he got elected, SO DOES THAT ARGUMENT REALLY
Oh [__] I just realized that I'm [__]
around and not ever shilling. Got an hour left on the stream.
Guys, if you like the content, go ahead and follow me on every
platform. Join the Discord, discord.gg/Jidion.
If you really like the content, you can make more of it happen,
okay? You can donate, you can sub. Couple ways you can donate
monetarily to the stream. That will prolong the stream, all right?
We've got quite a few quite a few piece of content left, so I
would like to go
We've got the Fuentes
the Fuentes video from Ezra Klein. We've possibly got some Tom
10, all right? I think there's possible Tom 10. I asked some
people to look at it real quick. We'll see if it if there's something
there. I think we might cover some of the the Destiny stuff later
today.
I forget. I think there was something I was planning to cover.
I don't know if it overlaps with what we did yesterday or not.
We'll have to see. We'll just have to see.
yeah, there's still quite a few pieces of content. Anyway, so
yeah, if you guys want to donate, all right.
You can do that a couple ways. You can sub on Kick individually
or you can give subs on Kick. You can buy a TTS message. Exclamation
boy donate in the chat will give you the links. You can give
kicks over on Kick, all right? You can't give primers right now
cuz Twitch Prime Twitch is closed. Twitch is dead to me. Twitch
[__] me over, okay? They they timed me out today
for a day.
All right, so you can't give primers. But everything else, that's
all an option. There's also the Patreon,
Extra content some nights, all right? I don't know about tonight.
Probably if I if we end in an hour or something, we'll do extra
content tonight.
Say something about an orbital listener regarding Destiny. Yeah,
he I heard he did that. I don't know if we'll cover it. Maybe
we'll cover it if we go to the what do you call it? The
If we go to
an order call supporter call Patreon call, we'll probably cover
that, maybe. We'll see. Anyway, let's continue. matter. He is
now the mayor elect
Cheap applause. I respect it though. So it whatever he did worked.
So I the reason I don't want to stay on it is because I think
there's a lot we can say about it, but what I'm trying to say
is he had people that were really glad to see someone who had
taken his views run for mayor and succeed. He also had people
he needed to reassure who had disagreement, but he recognized
that he was in coalition with a lot of people who had different
views, including he was asked about Abigail Spanberger and he
was asked about Mikey Sherrill and he said that that this is
a party that has room for everybody, not just people who look
like me. And I think that to me is what I I hate Republicans.
If you can unseat a Republican, it's good. It's Wait, Kringel
Canish, you know that like Obama's got pictures with uh like
Farrakhan and stuff, right?
Do you you say just if you have pictures with somebody, you you
inherit their policy? You inherit their their legacy?
Got some bad news for you about the entire US government and
a little dude named Jeff Epstein.
God damn. is good in my book. That was
This is so he's just lying. That's a That is a lie. Like this
guy is just I hate I don't hate Hassan, but I hate his dishonesty.
He's so dishonest. Like he He so obviously wears different hats.
You never really know what kind of Hassan you're going to get
depending on who you talk to him. Like He of course he doesn't
believe this. He didn't endorse Kamala. Not to go Wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait. Wait. Hold on. recognize Spanberger look
my book. And I think that to me is what I have to listen to Hassan
again cuz I didn't I didn't quite catch what he said, okay? I
hate Republicans. If you can unseat a Republican, it's good.
It's good in my book. That was my
This is so he's just lying. That's a That is a lie. Like this
guy is just I hate I don't hate Hassan, but I hate his dishonesty.
He's so dishonest. Like he He so obviously wears different hats.
You never really know what kind of Hassan Wait, what if What
if Hassan's point here was
I didn't I didn't endorse Kamala as openly as I should have and
I think I contributed to Trump getting elected like in some small
way or it keeps me up at night that that's a possibility. And
so I actually just support Dems now. You know, if you can unseat
a Republican in the current system, it's fine. What if that was
his point?
Would I wonder what Hutch would do.
Would Hutch Would Hutch embrace Hasan as a brother? You guys
think? Hasan, you're going to get, depending on who you talk
to him, like of course he doesn't believe this. He didn't Oh,
I'm not saying that's his point right now. I'm saying what if
Hasan said that was his point. Would Hutch embrace him as a brother?
He endorsed Kamala. Not to go belabor the point. I don't want
to spend too much time revisiting that, but obviously that wasn't
the case in 2024.
anger and resentment with like the way that the Democrats were
representing themselves during that campaign where it kind of
felt like they didn't hate Republicans too much. Whenever I hear
Nancy Pelosi say, "Oh, we need a strong Republican party." I'm
like, "No, we don't need a Republican party. We want to run this
country." Of course, and it's pretty ironic considering he's
in a uni-party country right now and just gassing it up like
crazy. There was nothing wrong with what Nancy Pelosi was What
she was saying was we need a sane, rational Republican party.
That's what she was saying. But she's not delusional enough to
think that you're going to be able to convince everybody in the
country to be Democrats or whatever party whatever vanguard party
he wants to turn it into or whatever. That's what she was saying.
We need a Republican party that is not a cult of personality
around Donald Trump. You know, there was a time in American history.
I know, I know, I know. Take a deep breath. There was There was
a time in American history where the Republican party was not
totally insane. There were always insane Republicans in Congress,
but the party itself, the party apparatus, like Mitt Romney was
not insane. He had policies that I certainly disagreed with.
I'd have to go back and look at his platform. I don't I mean
I don't even really remember, but um I'm sure he had a lot of
policies that I disagreed with or he had a lot of foreign policy
takes that I disagreed with. He was not crazy. And if he would
have been elected, it wouldn't have been the end of the world.
It would have led to worse outcomes, but it wouldn't have been
like what we're seeing right now. That's what she was talking
about. We're always going to have a Republican party. We're always
going to have like an opposition party. We're I don't Maybe not
it's not always going to be called the Republican party, but
we're always going to have different parties in this country.
Maybe maybe we become a multi-party country at some point. Maybe
we to adopt a parliament structure. I don't know, but there's
always going to be different parties. And as long as there is
a Republican party, we need a party that a When she said strong,
she didn't mean like electorally strong. She meant like strong
enough to resist
the whims of a tyrant like Donald Trump. That's what she meant
by that. in every seat and be so successful that you have a weak
and feckless and ineffective Republican party that cannot undermine
the agenda that centers the working class. That's what I want.
And so here's what I want to come back to.
I just I don't know if you guys can see his face as well as I
can. It's probably pretty strong small on your screen, but he's
just
ripping with contempt. What I would want is I want a one-on-one
discussion with these two. Talking about the overlap of the ways
in which Zahran built a big enthusiastic base of support, talking
about the ways in which Democrats have a void of not people not
really knowing what they stand for, which lets them be buffeted
by issues where they're kind of whether it's trans issues or
other kind of issues where they feel like they're on their heels
and there's this debate about throwing people under the bus.
What are the lessons that you think Democrats should be taking
from the success on Tuesday? You know, Chuck Schumer was afraid
to
So I I I Yeah. >> So So I I This is now going to be the
third time Chuck Schumer has been booed at a Democratic event
I've been at in 48 hours. And That's one thing that that I'm
happy to unite with the left on, the far left. Happy to join
their ranks or have them join our ranks or form a collective
rank. Chuckie boy's got to go. I think it's past that time. At
this point, it's time. It's time for him to go. All right. You
ready? The former Republican's going to praise Chuck Schumer
right now. The shutdown strategy's worked pretty good. We're
doing great on the Giving him a little flat claps. Shutdowns
So this was recorded um
before the Democrats broke ranks and voted to fund the government.